Ich gebe zu vielleicht etwas ungewöhnliche Uhrzeit, aber ich habe in letzter Zeit zu
wenig gestreamt.
Ich habe mir gedacht, komm jetzt machst du wenigstens mal an.
Will ich mal zum streamen da.
Ja montag 13 Uhr 18 sind glaube ich die meisten nicht da, aber letztendlich gut.
Ich habe gerade übelst gefressen sage ich euch.
Mozzarella Sticks vom Lidl.
Richtig Peppofett gefuddert.
Massive Peppofett.
Mozzarella Sticks Pommes frites in den Ofen geschmissen und auf gehts Peppofett.
Ist Chinesen Shopping heutzutage nicht verboten?
Das ist die Frage.
Wenn du Chinesen kaufen willst, dann ist das bestimmt verboten, aber wenn du in China einkaufen
willst, dann ist das ok.
Aber ich glaube generell Menschenhandel ist verboten, also nicht nur mit Chinesen.
Ich war letzte Woche teilweise krank, aber ich habe immer noch dicken Hals.
Ich weiß nicht woran das liegt.
Corona ist es nicht.
Ich habe zum ersten Mal einen Corona Test gemacht, obwohl ich geimpft bin.
Ich bin da doppelt geimpft seit ein paar Wochen, also das kann es eigentlich nicht sein.
Hast du Feierabend?
Nö, ich arbeite montags nie.
Ich arbeite nur vier Tage die Woche.
Ich habe die doofe Vermutung, ich bin vielleicht gegen irgendetwas allergisch, von dem ich
auch nichts weiß.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Du darfst heutzutage nichts mehr sagen.
Es geht was durch ganz Deutschland, dass wir das gleiche hatten, habe ich so glaube ich
meine Zweifel.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist doch recht gering.
Vier Tage Woche ist cool.
Hä?
Ist cool?
Q?
Was Q?
Gut?
Cool.
Caval.
Früher hat man das Caval geschrieben, wenn man richtig in deutschen Foren noch unterwegs
war, wo noch nicht alle auf Englisch geschrieben haben oder in Newsgroups damals und da hat
man dann geschrieben Caval, das ist richtig dumm.
Heutzutage bin ich in gar keinen Foren mehr unterwegs, schon gar nicht mehr in deutschen
Foren, weil ich muss jetzt nicht immer auf dem Mikrocontroller Forum rumhacken, aber
die sind zum größten Teil alle so.
So, also jetzt mal hier kurz schauen.
Also nein, ist nicht wie gesagt nicht verboten.
Für welche Sachen würdest du AliExpress sehen, für welche Alibaba?
Naja, wenn ich Sachen privat kaufe in normaler Stückzahl, dann auf jeden Fall AliExpress.
Alibaba ist ja eher sowas in der Richtung kaufe 1000 Sensoren oder so, das ist vielleicht
ein bisschen viel.
Also meine USB-Kabel, ich habe mir ja mal so ein 50er-Pack USB-Kabel gekauft, zwei Meter
lang.
Das hätte man durchaus vielleicht bei Alibaba machen können, aber in der Regel ist Aliexpress
eigentlich das, wo man als normaler Käufer kauft.
Alibaba ist die Business-to-Business, wie sagt man, die B2B-Seite, die Business-to-Business-Seite
von denen.
Das ist zwar heute nicht, aber macht nichts.
Genau, B2B, korrekt.
Das ist wohl wahr, das sind echt so die Spezialisten, die das Mikro-Controller vorhaben, das ist
wirklich so ein ganz spezieller Platz, da würde ich niemanden raten zu fragen, es sei
denn, man ist sehr frustresistent.
Wobei man das geschickt machen muss, also der beste Tipp, Leute, der beste Tipp, wenn
man was nicht weiß und die Antwort dazu im Internet wissen möchte, von Leuten, die eventuell
Ahnung haben, ihr müsst so tun, als wisst ihr es, aber falsch reinschreiben.
Also der Reiz der Leute, auf etwas Falsches zu antworten, ist viel größer, als auf die
Frage danach zu antworten.
Also wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel wissen wollt, was weiß ich, wie man einen Rechner zusammen
baut, dann bringt das nichts, wenn man ins Forum geht, na gut, Rechner zusammen, das
ist noch zu einfach, die Frage, sagt hier, wie baue ich einen Rechner zusammen, dann
hast du ganz viele sinnlose Antworten, so nach dem Motto, google doch mal eine Runde,
lull, dafür muss man doch nicht den Reddit fragen oder nicht den Forum fragen, wenn
du reinschreibst, Leute, ich weiß, wie man einen Rechner zusammen baut, du musst die
Grafikkarte in USB Slots stecken, dann kriegst du die korrekten Antworten auf Reddit, so
nach dem Motto, ah, bist du dumm, so macht man das gar nicht, guck mal hier, so sieht
das bei mir im Rechner aus, ja, man muss quasi die falsche Antwort geben, damit man die Richtige
bekommt.
Tanzer, dankeschön, übrigens Leute, es gibt was Neues, ich habe Sub-Badges anfertigen
lassen, die werden jetzt, die werden den Keks replaßen, ich denke, ich gehe mal davon aus,
das gefällt euch, wartet mal, ich zeige es euch mal, guck mal hier, es gibt jetzt Sub-Badges,
wobei ich mir noch nicht ganz sicher bin, in welcher Reihenfolge die kommen, also ich
würde ja sagen, ich würde ja sagen, Holz ist der Initiale, gefolgt von dem normalen
Cute Keks, ja, also ich würde sagen, warte mal, wir kopieren das jetzt, kopieren das
jetzt mal kurz, also ich würde sagen, das funktioniert so, das hier ist der erste, den
man kriegt, das ist der zweite, das ist der dritte, so und hier bin ich mir nicht sicher,
ich würde eigentlich sagen, das ist der vierte und das ist der fünfte, man das ist zwar
der Diamant Keks, der müsste eigentlich ein bisschen höher sein, aber der hat halt als
einziger Keks noch so ein Zusatzfeature, mit Kette, eigentlich müsste Diamant 5 sein,
aber der mit Kette ist cooler, guck mal, der mit Kette hat einen eigenen Gesichtsausdruck
und eine Kette, deswegen habe ich eigentlich gedacht, wir machen das umgedreht, der Goldene,
der Premium Gold Keks kommt auf die 5, man startet mit Holz, ich habe noch ein paar mehr,
ich habe auch noch Bronze und Eisen und so, aber das unterscheidet sich zu wenig, wenn
es zu klein ist, ich habe auch noch einen mit Hut, aber das Problem ist, Sub-Batches,
die müssen so rechteckig sein, weil ansonsten hast du ein Problem, wenn die nicht rechteckig
sind, stell euch mal vor, ihr habt hier beispielsweise Sub-Batches, ich habe das ja sogar noch größer
gemacht, in Wirklichkeit ist die Sub-Batch ja nur so klein, hat jemand von euch den Chat
auf 100% stehen oder habt ihr den alle auch rangezoomed, weil ich, ganz ehrlich, das
sind Boomer Augen vielleicht, aber ich finde, der Chat ist mit 100% einfach zu klein, ah,
du hast IRC, ja, das natürlich, 25%, ah so, ja so ist der Chat auch nicht schlecht, also
so, wisst ihr, hier passt einfach mehr drauf, hier passt einfach mehr drauf, alles bloated,
hier erkennt man das, so und wenn es halt nicht quadratisch, zumindest nicht irgendwie
halbwegs quadratisch ist, ist es halt zu klein, so und ich habe noch einen Keks mit einem
Hut auf, der ist eigentlich auch richtig nice, den habe ich jetzt aber nicht hier, kann ich
euch nicht zeigen, der ist aber dann glaube ich zu klein, weil dann steht hier oben so
da noch der Hut ein Stückchen raus, die müssten echt gut passen, ja Fedora hat, ja ist echt
so, deswegen hat er ja einen, ja aber ich glaube so mache ich das, naja gut, die Musik
weiß wieder nicht, welche Lautstärke sie haben wollen, finde ich immer toll, ja aber
das mache ich als nächstes rein, heute nicht, ich muss das noch ein bisschen resizeen, aber
nächsten Streams mache ich das dann rein, dann kriegen endlich die Leute, die hier teilweise
schon 15 Monate oder sonst was subscribt haben, die kriegen dann hier ihren entweder Diamant
oder Gold Keks, weiß gar nicht wieviel Sub-Batches man mittlerweile auf Twitch hochladen kann,
bei dir im Büro ist das Surferraum, Tainser dankeschön für den Sub, gut 27 Monate, bei
mir im Büro ist heute Surferraum abgesoffen, abgesoffen heißt wirklich Wasser oder es ist
einfach was abgekackt, weil Wasser ist schlecht, da werdet ihr wahrscheinlich die nächste Woche
nichts mehr da machen mit, bis es alles trocken ist, normalerweise hätte ich gesagt natürlich
ist damit gemeint, es ist einfach gecrashed und es ist nichts schlimmes, aber das weiß
man ja aktuell nicht, es gibt ja durchaus Sachen, die abgesoffen sind in letzter Zeit
so, ich glaube ich kann mich ja nicht mal selbst time outen, das ist zu, ich hab mir
auch so Dinge überlegt, genau sowas habe ich mir auch im Vorfeld überlegt, aber das
ist einfach zu klein bei den ganzen Batches, du kannst da nicht so viel machen, das ist
ein guter Titel für heute, ihr müsst jetzt nicht ausprobieren, na gut so, jetzt habe
ich die eigentlich alles noch auf, meine Güte, jetzt habe ich die alles auf, ich hatte
gar nichts mehr auf, guck mal hier, null, von gestern, ganzer Crap, stell den Porn weg
man, das ist das, ich hab extra einen Streamer Account, das ich nicht aus Versehen irgendwelche
Sachen zeige, die ich nicht zeigen will, außer ich zeige den Rec Ordner aus Versehen wieder,
aber ansonsten habe ich unter anderem, damit mir nicht irgendwelche dummen Sachen passieren
in einem extra Streaming Account, den ich nur dafür verwende, ja und sei es auch nur, dass
ich irgendwelche Rechnungen mit Real Life Adresse leake oder sowas, ich mach mal kurz
meine VM an, AliExpress wird immer am besten über die VM gebraust, August muss eingeschaltet
werden, ne ne ne nicht die Qt VM, die Qt VM könnte ich mal wieder updaten, die ist ja
schon hoffnungslos veraltet, Leute seid ihr mit dem Wahlergebnis zufrieden, ist was rausgekommen
was euch gefällt, nein es ist keiner zufrieden diesmal, das finde ich lustig, niemand, keine
Seite ist wirklich zufrieden, ja mal gucken was da rauskommt, ich bin gespannt, ups, jetzt
doppelt auf, ich kann mein T-Max nicht verlassen Leute, Anzeige ist raus, ist das ein Bug,
ich kann mein T-Max nicht zumachen, das startet sich immer wieder neu in meine Shell, warum,
ah hier geht das, ok wisst ihr was, Reboot, wenn man nicht genau weiß was abgeht erstmal
Reboot, das bestimmt, bestimmt der Chat, der Chat hat irgendwas Hacker-Manned auf meiner
Linux VM, gibts zu Leute, ist das das China Betriebssystem, ja klar sieht man ja schon
im Hintergrund, wir wissen ja, dass die Chinesen besonders Wert auf Umweltschutz legen, deswegen
ist der Hintergrund auch so grün, eh jetzt gehts wieder, ok ich hab keine Ahnung warum,
was das jetzt war, also machen wir Aliexpress auf, oh ja das wollte ich, das hab ich mir
tatsächlich mal überlegt noch welche zu bestellen, das könnte ich jetzt eigentlich
gleich machen, eh diese Chinesen Seiten, die sehen alle so unglaublich spammy aus, ich
kann das nicht anders beschreiben, die sind die, also Amazon ist ja relativ zurückhaltend
was Popups und sowas angeht, Amazon schreibt zwar an jeder Ecke so nach dem Motto, jetzt
im Amazon Sparabo, jetzt noch Prime dabei, jetzt noch hier irgendwie Versicherung oder
sonst was, aber die China Seiten sind ganz furchtbar ätzend, guckt euch das mal an,
also mal im Ernst, wenn jemand noch nie bei Aliexpress oder Banggood oder so, Banggood
gibts ja auch noch bestes, bestes, bester Seitenname übrigens überhaupt, Banggood gibts
noch, da gibts noch hier, DHGate und solche Geschichten, diese Seiten sehen erstens alle
gleich aus, ich mein guckt euch, ok DHGate, aber guckt euch mal, die sehen wirklich verdammt
ähnlich aus, diese ganzen China Seiten, also guckt euch das mal an, die Seiten sehen wirklich
verdammt ähnlich, aber mal angenommen jemand kennt nur Amazon und geht zum ersten mal
auf Aliexpress, der denkt doch, das ist Scam oder, der denkt doch nicht, dass das irgendwie
eine Seite ist, wo man wirklich legit was bestellen kann, ich verstehe nicht so genau, warum das
so ist, aber vielleicht kommt es ja bei den chinesischen Chinesen an, nein keine Nachrichtigungen,
das ist da auch weg, das ist da auch weg, diese Floating Popups sind ja noch schlimmer,
also ich hab letzte Woche was bekommen von Aliexpress, das war das erste, das war das
erste was ich je bestellt habe, das erste was ich je bestellt habe, nein das stimmt
vollkommen falsch ausgedrückt, das erste was ich wieder bestellt habe, seit es diese
Zollregelungen gibt, so das wollte ich sagen und kam ohne Probleme an, also ich hab bis
jetzt da noch keine schlechten Erfahrungen mitgemacht, hast du eigene Meinung, erfang
zu den Shelley Produkten, hattest du überlegt, ob ich mir von den Steckdosen holen soll,
ja das Zeug ist ganz gut, ich hab einige Shelley Sachen am Start, ich hab eine Shelley Steckdose
am Start, ich hab ein paar Shelley Ones am Start, ich hab einige Shelley Geräte noch
hier, beispielsweise den Shelley 1 PM, dann hab ich noch einen 2,5 oder was das für die
Rollos ist, aber ich hab nur die Shelley 1 im Einsatz und eine, glaub ich sind wirklich
nur eine Steckdose, die sind ok, das Problem bei den Shelley Dingern ist, wenn man davon
viele kaufen will, also gerade Steckdosen sind leider ein bisschen teuer im Vergleich zu
selbstgeflächten China Dingern, ne, das Shelley Plug kostet halt einfach mal, nein, das ist
überhaupt kein, das ist Chebated, ok wir müssen mal, ah da ist er doch, ich find's übrigens
toll, dass man nach Shelley Plug sucht und das erste, was er findet ist nicht der Shelley
Plug, gibt's eben, wir müssen mal kurz mal den auf der Seite gucken, es ist Chebated,
Shop Product, Shelley, wo ist es denn, Plug, achso es gibt noch mehr, das wusste ich gar
nicht, ach das Ding gibt's wirklich, was ist denn das, das ist ja richtig fett, wer braucht
denn sowas, das ist doch auch ein reprintedes China-Chinesen Ding, das hab ich, das Teil,
und das ist die Kokona, soll euch eigentlich mal aufgefallen, dass das aussieht, die Ami
Dose, dass das aussieht wie so ein Sad, Sad Emote, das hat schon gewisse Ähnlichkeiten,
oder?
Ah gut, wenn ich teilweise die Kokona Installationen sehe, müsste ich auch weinen, am besten ist
bei den Amis immer noch, wenn ich die Videos sehe, wo dann einer sagt, altes Haus umgebaut
auf neue Netzwerktechnik, und das erste was er macht ist eine Säge holen und die Wand
aufschneiden, und dann denk ich mir auch immer, alles klar, so Just Kokona Things, das funktioniert
hier halt nicht, ja, so das Problem ist, dass die leider ein bisschen teuer sind, guck mal,
du kriegst einen Viererpack für 64 Euro, du kriegst für die Hälfte, für die Hälfte
kriegst du bei Amazon einen China-Chinesen Ding zum Selbstflaschen, und bei AliExpress
wahrscheinlich auch, die Sache ist nur die, dass es aktuell schwierig ist, rauszubekommen,
was flashbar ist und was nicht, was passiert eigentlich, wenn man hier nach das Motor Steckdose
sucht?
Okay, ja guck, du siehst, du kriegst für ungefähr die Hälfte, und das geht noch
billiger, wenn das im Angebot ist, bekommst du auch einen Viererpack China Steckdosen,
die man flashen kann, wenn die mit USB sind, dann hab ich vielleicht sogar eine Abwandlung
davon, wenn die unten einen USB haben, es gibt ja nur 5-6 verschiedene Typen, immer
aktuelle Typen China Steckdosen, und, warte mal, kann man die hier flashen?
Man muss immer nach halbwegs aktuellen Bewertungen gucken, wo was drin steht, ob man die flashen
kann oder nicht, also flashen, gut, aber das vom ersten März, das ist schon ein bisschen
zu alt, also das ist schon ein bisschen zu alt die Info, Tasmota fähig, kann Berichtner
6.7. gekauft haben ohne Probleme Tasmota-Flashen, ja, also wichtig, wichtig, dass man die flashen
kann, und dann würde ich dieses Zeug hier, geflashed mit Tasmota auf jeden Fall, allein
schon wegen dem Preis, so den Shelley-Plugs vorziehen, aber man muss sagen, wenn man einfach
nur so eine Reinsteck-Steckdose, Zwischenstecker-Steckdose fürs WLAN haben will, kann man mit den Shelley-Dingern
eigentlich nichts falsch machen, die haben eine gute Firmware drauf, also da musst du
auch nichts flashen, du kannst die flashen, die sind relativ offen, lassen sich steuern
über HTTP, über MQTT, ohne irgendwie China-Cloud und App, Möglichkeiten mit App gibt's, braucht
man aber nicht, also die Shelley-Dinger sind firmware-technisch wirklich deutlich besser
als das Standard-China-Crap-Zeug, aber preislich ist es halt so ein Ding, denn du bezahlst glaube
ich ja auch noch Versand dabei, können wir mal kurz gucken, was sich das am Ende kostet,
das ist jetzt schon eine Offi, was, nein, Wollt ihr mich chibänen, warum legen die da so komisches
Zeug mit rein, Shipping 2 Euro, ja ich muss doch erstmal mein Land angeben oder, ja mann,
du bezahlst 3, du kriegst ja fast, du kriegst ja fast 12, ok sag mal du kriegst 10 Steckdosen
davon für den Preis von 4 Shelley-Steckdosen, da können die Dinger noch so offen sein, dann
würde ich lieber bei Amazon den Kram kaufen und, also nicht, das war nur ein Beispiel,
ja, ich hab ja einige, ich hab ja einige Steckdosen, ich guck mal, ich guck mal wie die letzten
hießen, die ich gekauft hab, die finde ich nämlich vom Gesamtpaket her bis jetzt von
allen am besten, ich werd von komischen Leuten eingeladen, hä, ich hab gerade eine Einladung
gekriegt, von der Arbeit, kalendertechnisch, Donnerstag 16 bis 17 Uhr, wer macht denn sowas?
Geh ich nicht hin, es gibt eine Tasmota Liste, die ist aber nicht aktuell, also das kommt
immer auf dem Firmware Stand an, ich find Amazon Bewertung besser, also ich zeig euch
mal kurz, ich zeig euch mal kurz was ich zuletzt gekauft hab, die finde ich eigentlich
bis jetzt von allen am besten, ich muss mal kurz in meine History gucken, mal kurz, Orders,
Orders Search Orders, Steckdose, ja, oh die gibt's nicht mehr, ha, super, die gibt's
nicht mehr, SmartSocket2USB, vielleicht gibt's die mittlerweile mit anderen Dingen, nee,
ich hab nämlich welche gekauft mit zwei USB Anschlussen unten, die sehen bisschen aus
wie die aber eckiger, und das ist, so sehen die aus im Prinzip, ja mehr oder weniger,
das glaub da sind die sogar, das, das, das könnten die, das könnten die sogar eins zu
eins sein, die ich hab, so, das finde ich sind bis jetzt die besten, weil, du hast ganz
normal, die sind relativ klein im Vergleich zu manch anderem, also auch nicht viel größer
als die normalen, auch nicht viel kleiner als normale groß, aber für das was sie können
auch, nee für die Steckdosenleiste sind die nix, für die Steckdosenleiste sind die zu
fett, für die Steckdosenleiste musst du kleine Runde kaufen, wenn du was für eine
Steckdosenleiste willst, dann musst du kleine Runde kaufen, allerdings die bessere Variante
ist, kauf dir eine flashbare Steckdosenleiste, viel besser, hier hab ich auch drei Stück
rum stehen, hier steht einer für den, es sieht dann so aus, das ist ein Motor, muss
mal kurz gucken, sowas hier, gucken ob ich da irgendwas, genau, ja, das ist jetzt dummes
Beispiel, weil, tja, ich hab jetzt keine Adresse aus dem Kopf für eine Steckdosenleiste,
aber da hast du hier fünf verschiedene Knöpfe zum an und ausschalten, wenn du die mit Custom
Firmware geflasht hast, anstatt einen Knopf zum an und ausschalten, fünf verschiedene
Knöpfe, wenn du übers Webinterface gehst, also das ist nicht schlecht, genau, also das
sind die letzten die ich mir gekauft habe, ich glaube das sind die, weil meine, ich hab
in meine Amazon Historie geguckt, die gibt's nicht mehr, exakt die die ich gekauft hab,
aber das ist bisher finde ich die beste Kombination gewesen, weil die sind mit Custom Firmware
flashbar gewesen, muss mal gucken ob das immer noch so ist und du kannst den Main, Strom
und USB Steckdosen kannst du getrennt schalten, wartet mal, ich gucke mal ob ich, ich schau
mal kurz auf den zweiten Bildschirm in meine Heimautomatisierung rein und dann zeige ich
euch mal das Webinterface, Integration, Tasmota, Tasmota Integration, sechs Geräte, Tasmota
Keller, ah cool, hier, ich zeige euch erstmal die Steckdosenleiste, wo ich aus irgendwelchen
Gründen weil ich dumm bin die nicht aktiviert hab, hier, Tasmota Keller habe ich hier zu
bieten, Tasmota Keller, das ist die Steckdosenleiste im Keller, da hängt, was Raspberry Pi, nein
Raspberry Pi hat nichts zu tun, da hängt aktuell dran, lass mal überlegen was hängt
da am Keller dran, das Deck Ding für die Türgegensprechanlage, das Analog Ding für die Türgegensprechanlage
und Raspberry Pi am USB und die zwei sind noch frei, genau, so sieht das dann halt mit
der Steckdosenleiste aus, da kannst du hier die Steckdosenleiste schalten, natürlich
ist das nicht gedacht, dass man so übers Webinterface schaltet, weil das Webinterface hat eine relativ
unaussagekräftige Beschriftung, ich gehe davon aus man kann in Tasmota auch die Knöpfe
hier anpassen, dass dann was steht, was was ist, aber normalerweise binden man das dann
halt entweder über HTTP oder MQTT in seine Heimautomatisierung ein und steuert das da
drüber, so, so sieht das Webinterface von der Steckdosenleiste aus, das heißt, wenn
ich mir sowas hier kaufen würde und sage, ich will das in eine Steckdosenleiste stecken,
dann würde ich mir vielleicht überlegen, ob ich mir nicht gleich eine Steckdosenleiste
kaufe, die ich komplett schalten kann, so wie das hier, ich beantworte gleich das ganze
Sachen im Chat, ich muss nur gerade mal schauen, wo ich das andere habe, das müsste nämlich
was im Bad sein hier, Gosund, Badklo, Badklo Strom, Badklo USB, das klingt gut, da habe
ich die IP nicht eingeblendet, das muss ich mal kurz machen, aktivieren, aktualisieren,
in 30 Sekunden wird die IP hinzugefügt, ok, dann müssen wir 30 Sekunden warten, dann
kriege ich die IP raus, ja, dann sage ich jetzt kurz noch was zu den Questions, würdest du
sagen, dass das ganze Smart Home-List, was braucht man das wirklich, das kommt noch wann,
was du damit machen willst, wenn du einfach nur Spielereien damit machst, dann brauchst
du das nicht, aber ich würde dir allen empfehlen, mit sinnvollen Dingern anzufangen, die dir
auch wirklich das Leben erleichtern, sei es nur eine Anzeige, ob dein Zug pünktlich ist
oder dass du beispielsweise siehst, was du für einen Stromverbrauch hast, falls dich
das interessiert, dass du sagen kannst, hey guck mal, nachts verbraucht irgendwas Strom,
mit einfachen sinnvollen Dingern anfangen, zum Beispiel, was viele Leute, gehe ich mal
von aus, also eines der ersten Sachen, die ich gemacht habe, die ich bis heute immer
noch wahnsinnig praktisch finde, ist die Fenster, die man täglich zum Lüften aufmacht, Sensor
dran machen, wo man erkennt, ob die auf oder zu sind und dann, ich habe hier ein Dashboard
im Flur hängen und dann, bevor ich das Haus verlasse, kann ich auf das Dashboard gucken
und sehen, dass alles zu ist, alternativ kann man dann auch einstellen, wenn es erkennt,
dass man nicht mehr zu Hause ist und du hast ein Fenster vergessen, dann kann das Ding
dir auch beispielsweise eine Message aufs Handy schicken, so nach dem Motto Max dreh um, du
hast das Fenster im Bad vergessen, das sind so Sachen, das finde ich wirklich nice, ja
Smart Mirror ist was, wo ich sage, ist so ein Hinguckerprojekt, was ganz viele machen,
ich sehe den Sinn von einem Smart Mirror nicht, ich nehme eh mein Smartphone mit ins Bad, wozu
brauche ich dann ein Smart Mirror, den Sinn von einem Smart Mirror verstehe ich nicht,
das ist eher so ein Hinguckerprojekt, was viele machen, weil es cool aussieht.
Warum muss man das Licht vom Handy ausschalten können, naja, das kann schon ganz praktisch
sein, zum Beispiel, wenn du dich ins Bett legst und stellst fest, ah Mist, guck mal,
ich habe unten im Flur noch das Licht an und ich habe noch im Wohnzimmer das Licht an,
da kannst du einfach sagen, dass du entweder vom Handy aus das Licht schaltest, aber der
eigentliche Sinn von Smart Home ist ja nicht nur, oder ist ja erstmal nicht unbedingt,
dass du von Hand auf dem Handy alles das machst, was du sonst von Hand an einem Schalter machst,
sondern der eigentliche Mehrwert ist ja, dass es die Dinger automatisch macht, richtig,
genau, genau das, was 7-Eleven sagt, das ist nämlich der eigentliche Punkt, den auch viele
Leute immer verkennen, das ist der erste Schritt, der erste Schritt, den du machen musst ist
natürlich, du musst das Zeug in irgendeiner Art und Weise bedienbar machen, das heißt,
du hast dann auch ein Webinterface, wo du Sachen ausschalten kannst, aber der zweite Schritt
und der finde ich auch am meisten bringt, ist, dass du Sachen automatisch machst, ja,
zum Beispiel habe ich so eingestellt, dass drüben, wenn der Fernseher ausgeschaltet
wird nach 22 Uhr, dann dauert es noch 10 Minuten und da gehen die Lichter aus, das
ist eine sinnvolle Automatisierung, ja, und wenn man den Fernseher in der Zeit wieder
einschaltet, dann passiert halt nichts, solche Sachen, oder zum Beispiel, was auch viele
Leute haben, die haben die Ladestation vor dem Handy neben dem Bett liegen und dann kannst
du zum Beispiel einstellen, wenn du das Handy auf die Ladestation legst und es ist nach
22.30 Uhr, schaltest du nach 5 Minuten oder 10 Minuten das Licht aus und was du dann damit
halt auch machen kannst, gerade wenn du das mit offener Software machst, wo du halt auch
Custom Einstellungen dran machen kannst, dann kannst du dann auch so coole Sachen machen
wie, ok, wir machen vielleicht nicht das Licht komplett aus, sondern wir machen erst
einmal, wir dimmen vielleicht erst mal das Licht nur und dann machen wir nach einer halben
Stunde komplett aus oder sowas in der Richtung, also das ist schon ganz praktisch, was auch
praktisch ist, wenn ich beispielsweise die Tür zu meinem Serverraum aufmache, geht automatisch
das Licht an, weil da ein Bewegungssensor drin ist und sowas, also man muss erstmal gucken,
dass man sinnvolle Anwendungsgebiete findet, die einem auch das Leben erleichtern, ja.
Da kann ich ja nichts davor bewahren, wenn du es blöd einstellst, hast du es blöd eingestellt.
Ich würde auch nicht die Sachen über automatisieren, ich würde einfach das, wo es nervt, das wo
es nervt, würde ich automatisieren, ich habe beispielsweise meine ganze Zeit lang das so
eingestellt, dass automatisch sobald quasi 15 Minuten nachdem die Sonne aufgeht oder
zum Sonnenaufgang, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie ich das genau, wie ich das eingestellt habe,
dass unten in der Küche ging der Roller an und hoch, da haben wir so einen automatischen,
den kann man steuern, habe ich aber ausgeschaltet, ist sinnlos, erstens heißt es nicht automatisch,
dass man immer in dem Dreh aufsteht und außerdem hat es die Katze verrückt gemacht, weil die
Katze dachte, es ist jemand auf, weil sich der Roller anbewegt hat, also ist es nicht
alles sinnvoll.
Also das erste, was ich gemacht habe, das kann ich euch jetzt mal sagen, das war für
mich so der Einstieg in diese ganze Heimautomatisierung, weil ich mir gedacht habe, das ist eine coole
Idee, heute benutze ich das, also mittlerweile benutze ich das gar nicht mehr so richtig,
auch wenn ich das immer gerne als Beispiel bringe, weil ich habe mein Dashboard im Flur
hängen, ich brauche das nicht mehr, das erste, was ich gemacht habe ist, ich habe eine RGB-Lampe
geholt, habe die über den Eingang zu meinem Arbeitszimmer gehängt und jeden Morgen, wenn
ich aus meinem Schlafzimmer rausgekommen bin, dann hast du an der RGB, also an der Farbe
von der Lampe gesehen, ob da Zug pünktlich ist oder Verspätung hat, nachdem es eine RGB-Lampe
ist, habe ich das halt so eingestellt, dass es dynamisch quasi faden konnte, von grün
zu gelb, orange zu rot, zu dunkelrot, das war das erste, weil ich mir damals gedacht
habe, sobald du morgens aufstehst, oder noch im Bett teilweise, guckst du auf dein Handy,
ob der Zug losgefahren ist, und wenn der Zug rechtzeitig losgefahren ist, dann weiß ich
meistens, er kommt auch rechtzeitig an, und das ging mir so auf den Sack, dass ich da
jedes Mal morgens, bevor ich irgendwie im Bad was mache, habe ich immer aufs Handy geguckt,
natürlich wäre es nicht cool, wenn ich morgens einfach aus der Tür vom Schlafzimmer komme
und direkt sehe, ob pünktlich oder unpünktlich ist, so das war so das erste, wo ich mir
gedacht habe, das ist sinnvoll, so, und dann ging es bei mir eigentlich immer weiter, und
eine coole Geschichte, die beispielsweise sich auch lohnt, denke ich, für die meisten
Leute ist, dass man seine Heizung im Keller ein- und ausschalten kann, wenn man zur Miete
wohnt, da wird das Ganze natürlich nichts, aber dass man zum Beispiel seine Heizung im
Keller ein- und ausschalten kann, weil das ist ja so, wenn man so eine Zentralheizung
hat, die auch warm Wasser macht, da wird ja empfohlen, dass man zum Beispiel im Sommer,
wenn es warm ist, wenn du die Heizung nicht brauchst, dass du dann den Betriebsmodus
von der Heizung umschaltest, auf Heizen, warm Wasser, auf nur warm Wasser, so, und dann
muss man quasi in den Keller runter, muss ein Knopf bedrücken, und dann stellst du
fest, ah, jetzt ist doch abends schon ganz schön kühl, da musst du nochmal in den Keller
und sowas in der Richtung, das ist dann natürlich möglich, aber doof, und mittlerweile habe
ich einen Knopf, dann kann ich die Heizung einfach ein- und ausschalten, und wisst ihr,
was das Coole ist, wenn man dann in Richtung Automatisierung kommt, man kann dann auch
zeitgleich sagen, ok, man macht einfach einen Button in sein Home Assistant, Demo Home Assistant,
ich kann euch jetzt mein Dashboard nicht zeigen, weil da lieg ich zu viel, na, du machst einen
Button in dein Home Assistant Dashboard, hier, was weiß ich, Heizung, Heizung an, so, und
dann drückst du den Knopf, und dann würdest du dann mit nicht nur Triggern Heizung anmachen,
sondern du kannst dann damit auch Triggern, dass du die smarten Thermostate, die du beispielsweise
an zwei, drei Heizkörpern hast, automatisch damit auch wieder aus dem Sommersparmodus
in den Aktivmodus setzt, du hast dann quasi einen Button, der das dann macht, was du ansonsten
eigentlich von Hand überall hättest machen müssen, das sind dann so praktische Sachen,
aber da muss man, also ich muss sagen, das wichtigste ist da eigentlich erstmal so ein
bisschen rein zu kommen, weil viele Ideen hat man, ehrlich gesagt, wenn man dabei ist
und das macht, ja, und halt sinnvolle, sinnvolle, mit sinnvollen Sachen anfangen, ja, die meisten
Leute, die meisten Leute fangen an und machen irgendwelche komischen Ambilight Sachen und
sowas, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, RGB-Lampen ist das overratedste, was es gibt, 90% der
Leute wollen übrigens gar kein RGB, also bin ich wirklich überzeugt von, was 90% der
Leute, die sagen, ich will smarte Beleuchtung haben, was die wollen ist, eine Lampe, die
man remote an- und ausschalten kann, und eine Lampe, die man dimmen kann, das ist alles,
mehr wollen die nicht, eventuell, dass man noch die Weißfarbe einschalten kann, aber
eine wirkliche RGB-Lampe will eigentlich gar keiner haben, die Leute denken nur, dass sie
die haben wollen und dementsprechend geben sie unnötig viel Geld aus, es gibt ja die
unterschiedlichen, ich habe übrigens auch RGB-Lampen an den Stellen, wo ich es passend
finde, das kommt auch noch dazu, dass RGB-Lampen meistens, zumindest preisleistungsmäßig,
dann dunkler sind, aber es gibt ja verschiedene Abstufungen, was smarte Lampen angeht, es
gibt Lampen, die sind beispielsweise nur, also ich habe von denen einige Lampen, aber
die kann ich auch nicht so pauschal empfehlen, weil die viel zu teuer sind, das ist jetzt
übrigens tatsächlich sehr günstig gerade, wenn die im Angebot sind, also ich habe von
Liveaxe relativ viele, so und die haben auch verschiedene, das betrifft aber alle Hersteller,
ich zeige es euch jetzt nur mal anhand denen, weil ich die halt selbst habe und selbst verwende,
also die haben verschiedene Abstufungen und das ist auch sinnvoll, weil, man sieht es
hier zum Beispiel, man muss sich schon ein bisschen überlegen, die haben einmal welche,
die sind weiß, weiß heißt, es kann sein, dass ich mich jetzt hier vertue, aber ich
bin mir da relativ sicher, weiß bedeutet, es hat genau eine Farbe, wenn du sie anmachst,
aber du kannst sie remote über WLAN an- und ausschalten und du kannst sie dimmen, das
ist im Prinzip schon mal das, was 90% der Leute wollen, die wollen eine dimmbare Lampe
und die wollen eine Lampe, die man remote ein- und ausschalten kann, so, damit hättest du
eigentlich schon mal das meiste abgefackelt, das ist den Leuten bloß nicht klar, so, das
nächste, was du hast im Angebot ist, white to warm, sprich, das ist eine Lampe, da kannst
du dimmen, remote an- und ausschalten und den weiß Farbton einstellen, ich vermute mal,
das ist so realisiert, dass hier eine weiße LED drin ist und hier eine weiße und eine
rote LED drin ist, eventuell wird der Kram ja auch teurer mit der Zeit, weil du mehr
Hardware darin verbauen musst, so, und spätestens hier hast du wirklich 90% von dem, was die
Leute so im Haus haben wollen, abgedeckt, gibt es wirklich Leute, die ihren Flur lila
haben wollen oder grün oder ihre Abstellkammer meeresfarben oder so, natürlich, wenn ich
das so frage, natürlich gibt es Leute, die das wollen, aber die meisten, 90% der Leute
wollen das nicht, 90% der Leute wollen dimmen, die wollen vielleicht den weiß Ton einstellen
und remote ein- und ausschalten, das wars, das wars, das heißt, wenn man sich da erstmal
ein bisschen Gedanken zu machen mit der Materie beschäftigt, dann kommt man drauf, dass man
viel billiger vielleicht davon kommt, als so diese, ich kaufe mir jetzt einfach irgendwie
einen 10er Set Philips View und gebe irgendwie, was weiß ich, 300 Euro aus, hab dann dolle
RGB Lampen, aber ich brauch eigentlich gar kein RGB, so, und die nächste Lampe ist dann
das, was man sich vorstellt, RGB, so, dann gibt es die ganze noch, bei denen geht es
noch ein bisschen weiter, also das hier ist das, was die meisten Leute sich dann kaufen
fürs Haus, was aber komplett oversized und unsinnig ist, wie gesagt, für 90% oder 99%,
wie der Chat kann sein, so, die haben da noch ein paar andere, die hier sind leuchtstärker,
die hier sind 800 Lumen, die sind 1000 Lumen und die hier sind 1200 Lumen, das ganze gibt's,
das ist für die großen Stecker und das ist für die bisschen kleinere Stecker, das haben
die auch noch so kleinere Dinger und dann haben die noch was, was ich ganz cool finde,
sowas clean ist, weiß ich jetzt nicht, übrigens, die Preise auf der offiziellen Seite sind
viel zu teuer, guckt bei Amazon, das ist billiger, was ich noch ganz cool finde, ist die Night
Vision Variante, weil die Night Vision Variante, die hat eine 1200 Lumen RGB plus weiß RGBW
LEDs und eine Infrarot-LED, das ist wirklich sehr praktisch, weil ich hab eine Kamera unten
im Flur mit selbst ziemlich Müll-Infrarot-LED und die Lampe, die ich unten im Flur habe,
die macht normalerweise Licht für den Flur, aber nachts macht die Infrarot-Licht für
die Kamera und ich sehe wirklich alles in dem Flur, also, wenn die Katz nachts im Flur
unten sitzt und sich die Pfoten putzt, dann sehe ich quasi, an welchem Nagel die gerade
ist, so gut ist die Night Vision oder ist es beleuchtet mit der Lampe, natürlich wird
es dementsprechend, sowas clean ist, habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, das ist was
Neues, das sagt mir nichts, ich habe keinen Schimmer, was ist clean?
Desinfekt, was, die Anti-Corona-Lampe oder wie, das ist doch jetzt, das ist doch jetzt,
kann doch jetzt nicht sein oder?
Antibacteriälke, ok, ok, die Lampe macht Corona kaputt, alles klar, gut, das ist glaube
ich nichts, was ich bei mir im Flur installieren muss, wenn ich ehrlich bin, ja, oh ja, das
ist aber günstig, dass du mindestens 1200 Euro ausgeben, alles klar, super, ja, so,
das jetzt hier mal so als lange Sachen zu RGB Lampen, ja, ja, Philips Hue ist sicherlich
nicht verkehrt, aber preisleistungsmäßig unter aller Sau, was hast du alles, ja, ich
habe ja schon einige jetzt aufgezählt, ich bin permanent am basteln, das ist auch so,
sag mal so, das ist Komfort und Hobby in einem, zu diesen Sachen habe ich mir jetzt schon
genug ausgelassen.
Moin Max, mein Vater hat mich gefragt, ob ich ihm ein kleines und rechts kosteneffektives
nachbauen kann, hast du ein paar Tipps?
Ja, wenn dein Vater das verwenden will, ist für den einfache Bedienung denke ich mal
relativ wichtig, kauf irgendein kleines Synology fertig aus, ich würde nichts selbst bauen.
Wenn du irgendwas willst, was fix und fertig ist, was eine sinnvoll bedienbare Oberfläche
hat, was einfach geht, kauf ein Fertiges, so teuer sind die nicht und du musst dir keine
Gedanken mehr machen.
Ich habe mir eins selbst gebaut, aber das würde ich nicht irgendwie jemand anderem geben.
Ich suche was, womit ich über OBS von meinem PC auf ein anderes Display spiegeln kann,
das geht unter anderem über den Handy, das hast du per Vela als zweiten Monitor erkennen
lässt.
Was?
Du kannst Dings verwenden, wie ist das denn, dieses Netzwerkübertragungsding für OBS,
ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt, da gab es was, da kannst du umschalten, Alter, MonkaS,
Danny hat mich gehorstet, huge, jetzt hast du mich aber echt auf falschen Fuß erwischt,
wir sind hier gerade sinnlose Chinasachen einkaufen, danke für den Horst, OBS Ende,
ja ja, ja, willkommen Leute, und habt ihr schön in Warzone rumgeraged oder was war angesagt?
Solution Army, ja, Don Raven höchstpersönlich, Warzone umgeraged, ja was sonst, wo erkennst
du Solution, boah, also ich überlege gerade, also ja von YouTube, aber ich vermute mal,
ich vermute mal, ich glaube ursprünglich von irgendwelchen MW2 Videos, ich weiß gar
nicht, wie wir uns kennen, keine Ahnung, weiß nicht mehr genau, aber irgendwie aus
MW2, irgendwie aus MW2, wir haben ja damals auch ein paar Sachen zusammen aufgenommen,
witzig, MW2 Penta Nuke Spawn Trapping, oh ja, da kann ich mich auch dran erinnern, das
war noch so Zeiten, das war noch Zeiten, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, wo die
Leute dann rumgeflammt haben, dass irgendjemand dem anderen das Nuke Gameplay geklaut hat
und sowas in der Richtung, so nachdem, na ich hatte World First, ich hatte World First und
dann kam hier ein anderer und hat es dann hochgeladen, obwohl er nicht hochladen sollte
und dann war da ein riesiges Geflamer auf YouTube damals, man hat sich damals echt über ganz
schön viel Schwachsinn auf YouTube aufgeregt, so aus heutiger Sicht, die gefakte Penta Nuke
von Rambo war legendär, wisst ihr was wirklich legendär war, aus der damaligen, weil wir
zu viele Leute hier haben, wisst ihr was wirklich legendär war aus der damaligen Zeit, da ist
die Moab, ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendjemand kennt, wo ist das Video hin, hier, da ist
die Moab, da ist die Moab, das eigentliche Video ist aber weg, das gab es auch mal in
der 10-Stunden-Variante irgendwie, da ist die Moab, das 10-Stunden-Compilation-Video
ist anscheinend weg, das war echt legendär aus der damaligen Zeit, da ist die Moab, da
ist die Moab, oh man, aber man hat sich damals schon über total viel Schwachsinn aufgeregt
auf YouTube, ich kann mich da echt noch an Dinge erinnern, wo ich mir gedacht habe, Alter,
das war auch so die Zeit, wisst ihr, das war so die Zeit, wo sich alle drüber aufgeregt
haben über Partner werden und sowas, so nach dem Motto, ich habe damals auch ein Video
gemacht, so nach dem Motto, ich werde nie Partner auf YouTube und sowas in der Richtung,
erklär es mir, ich bin auch alt, denn in MW3 gab es noch eine Moab und da hat, ich glaube,
der Asiali war es damals, der hat so eine Challenge gemacht, dass die Leute sagen sollten,
da ist die Moab und der Typ hat gewonnen und irgendjemand hat dann so ein 10-Stunden-Video
davon gemacht, richtig bescheuert MW3 Kram und ja, stimmt, und dann haben alle damals
Werbung gemacht für irgendwelche Key-Shops und dann hatten Key-Shops einen schlechten
Ruf und dann wurde dann geflamet, warum machst du Werbung für Key-Shops, heute ist das teilweise
das Normalste von der Welt, dass die Leute Werbung machen für den übelsten Stuss, sei
es jetzt VPNs oder sowas oder Key-Shops oder hast du nicht gesehen und die verbinden das
nicht mal so sehr persönlich damit, ja, man hat sich schon echt über verdammt viel Schwachsinn
damals aufgeregt, ja, von Partner bis irgendwelche Gameplays geklaut, dann gab es dann auch
so Dinger nach dem Motto, das war meine Videoidee und es gab ja auch relativ viel Stress da
teilweise hinter den Kulissen wegen unglaublich viel kleinem, unsinnigem Kram, ja, das waren
aber auf jeden Fall noch andere Zeiten, so, jetzt kaufen wir weiter was in China ein,
das ExpressVPN wurde von einer Malware Firma gekauft, wirklich, das habe ich nicht mitbekommen,
aber das wundert mich nicht, ich habe dazu übrigens mal ein Video aufgenommen, Lügen
der VPN-Anbieter, also falls irgendwie einer wissen will, was ich von VPN-Anbietern halte,
der, achso, wer vielleicht nicht weiß, wer ich bin auf YouTube, ich bin der da, falls
es schon irgendjemand mal gesehen hat, daher kennen wir uns auch, der Danio nicht, und
ich habe mal ein Video gemacht zu, was ich von VPN-Anbietern halte und was da so versprochen
wird und dass ich das für ziemlich einen Schwachsinn halte, aber klar, man kann VPN-Anbieter
verwenden für manche Sachen, zum Beispiel, ja, wie soll man sagen, also eines der häufigsten
Anwendungszwecke ist sicherlich, dass die Leute sich von Torrents runterladen bis, fragt
mich nicht, wie die Seiten mittlerweile heißen, Börse.xyz, was auch immer, sich Dinger runterladen
wollen und nicht erwischt werden wollen, aber das ist ja nicht das, was die VPN-Anbieter
versprechen, die VPN-Anbieter versprechen zum größten Teil zu Sachen wie Super Privacy,
mit uns bist du vollständig anonym und sicher im Internet unterwegs und das ist halt Schwachsinn,
ja, dann VPN trägt nicht zwangsläufig dazu bei, kann, aber macht es nicht automatisch,
dazu bei, dass man anonym im Internet ist, am besten sind dann die Leute, die erstmal
einen VPN aufbauen und sich dann einloggen bei Google Mail oder sowas, ja, und dann denke
ich mir auch immer, warum brauchst du einen VPN auf, loggst du dann auf Google Mail ein,
zumindest cookie-mäßig weiß da jeder sofort, wer du bist, am besten auf dem gleichen Browser
oder sowas, er gibt keinen Sinn und auch alles nach dem Ausgang vom VPN ist ja auch nicht
mehr verschlüsselt, das ist nicht mein Home Assistant, das ist die Home Assistant Demo,
weil ich, bevor mich der Danny Gauss hatte, eigentlich gerade dabei war, mich über Smart
Home Geschichten auszulassen und ich mein Home Assistant Dashboard nicht zeigen kann,
weil ich dann zu viel Sachen liege.
Wir waren nämlich eigentlich gerade bei RGB-Lampen und ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich stehen geblieben
bin, zumindest war mein Fazit, dass RGB-Lampen nicht das sind, was 99% der Leute haben wollen,
weil 99% der Leute, also 90% der Leute wollen eine dimmbare Lampe, keine RGB-Lampe, genau
in Cognito-Modus, da bist du auch komplett unsichtbar, ist ja bekannt, ja, das ist wieder
was anderes, wenn du das, wenn du irgendwelche Tor Browser Geschichten oder so verwendest,
das ist ja wieder was anderes, das ist aber nicht das, was ein VPN macht, geschweige denn,
wenn du immer die gleiche, quasi für die ganze Session dich da mit deinem Account anmeldest
und immer über die gleiche VPN-Verbindung, das macht es nicht automatisch anonym, aber
das meiste ist schwachsinnig, was VPN-Anbieter versprechen.
Es ist ja übrigens auch gar nicht so, dass, also VPN-Anbieter sagen das ja, was nehmen
wir denn mal hier, NordVPN oder irgendwelche Geschichten, die sagen ja dann auch so Dinger
wie, es ist sicher, weil alles verschlüsselt ist und sowas, das stimmt schlicht und ergreifend
nicht, das stimmt einfach nicht, man gibt es das Smart Home Tour, ja wollte ich schon
lange mal machen.
Ein paar kleine Sachen habe ich ja schon gezeigt, zum Beispiel mein Heizungs-Dashboard, weiß
ich gar nicht, habe ich euch in letzter Zeit schon mal mein Heizungs-Dashboard gezeigt,
was by the way seit einer Weile schon kaputt ist, aber hier funktioniert hat noch, Massive
Heizungs-Dashboard, da sehe ich, wie warm die Abgase von der Heizung sind, ob meine Pumpe
funktioniert, ob der Brenner gerade brennt, Kessel-Temperatur, Solist-Temperatur, müsste
ich mal wieder einschalten.
Zumindest, jetzt nochmal ganz kurz zu dieser VPN-Geschichte, das ist ja schon das erste,
was nicht stimmt, sicheres Internet, der größte Fall, alle deine Daten werden von einer der
modernsten Verschlüsselungen geschützt, das stimmt schlicht und ergreifend nicht, das
einzige, was verschlüsselt ist in dem Fall ist, der Weg von dir zum VPN-Anbieter und
zurück, der Weg vom VPN-Anbieter zum eigentlichen Server, wo du hin willst, der ist vielleicht
verschlüsselt, wenn es HTTPS ist oder nicht und wenn es HTTPS ist, dann wäre es auch
verschlüsselt, ohne den VPN-Anbieter dazwischen, das stimmt schlicht und ergreifend nicht,
was da steht, das erweckt den Eindruck, als könnten deine Daten auf magische Art und Weise
nicht mal gelesen werden, nur weil du einen VPN-Anbieter verwendest, das betrifft nur
die Verbindung zwischen dir und dem VPN-Anbieter, nicht zwischen dem VPN und dem Server, wo
du eigentlich hin willst, der VPN liefert dir ja nicht die Webseite aus, die du haben
willst, macht Solution Werbung für einen VPN-Anbieter, weiß ich nicht, ganz ehrlich,
wenn die mich ordentlich bezahlen würden, dann würde ich auch Werbung für einen VPN-Anbieter
machen, ich würde halt nicht so einen Mist erzählen, sondern ich würde die Sachen erzählen,
die halt wirklich sinnvoll sind, da müsste ich halt mir überlegen, wie man das geschickt
umschreibt, aber wozu ist ja nur unbestreitbar, nützlich ist es zum Beispiel, wenn man Netflix
verwenden will, bei, keine Ahnung, in einem anderen Land oder sowas, dann ist das natürlich
sinnvoll, ja, oder wenn man zum Beispiel Public, das ist auch sowas, wenn man den Public Hotspot
verwendet, dann ist das, da kann das auch sinnvoll sein, also es gibt ja durchaus Vorteile
um einen VPN zu verwenden, aber das meiste, was angepriesen wird, ist halt so, sagen wir
mal, legen wir das mal wohlwollend aus, es ist nur teilweise richtig, was da steht, also
es erweckt auf jeden Fall einen umfassenderen Schutz, ich habe auch schon VPN-Anbieter gelesen,
die irgendwas von Antivirus und Gedöns geschrieben haben, wo ich mir denke, wie zum Geier sollen
VPN Antivirus-Krams machen und wenn es das macht, dann müsste es ja irgendwie sogar noch
mal eine Verbindung reingucken, ja, wie gesagt, es gibt durchaus Anwendungsgebiete für einen
VPN, keine Frage, ich verwende auch manchmal VPNs, da muss ich halt nur fragen, für was
verwendet man das und ist es dafür sinnvoll, zu sagen, ah ja gut, der VPN-Anbieter sagt
sicheres Internet, ja hier alles verschlüsselt, ist klar, ich verwende das, stimmt halt schlicht
und ergreifend nicht, ja, Region-Blocks umgehen vollkommen in Ordnung, also hat schon seinen
Anwendungszweck, ja, wir verkaufen keine Daten, das ist auch was, das ist schlicht und ergreifend
nicht überprüfbar für mich als Kunde, wo soll ich das wissen und jetzt überlegt euch
mal, es gab genug Seiten, wo die gesagt haben, nein nein, wir loggen nichts und bei uns sind
eure Daten sicher und sonst was, ihr könnt ja mal, ach hier Richie, moin, was wollte
ich jetzt sagen, die gesagt haben, wir loggen nichts, bei uns ist das alles sicher, ja,
ich weiß irgendwelche File-Sharing-Geschichten oder irgendwelche Foren oder sonst was, das
haben uns ganz viele Seiten schon gesagt und dann steht die Polizei vor der Tür und sagen
hier Jungs, geb her und dann machen die mit, also das ist einfach eine Aussage, die kann
stimmen oder auch nicht, ich muss davon ausgehen, dass es nicht stimmt, weil ich habe keine
Möglichkeit das zu überprüfen, also ist bescheuert, sicheres Streaming, dass es wohl
wahr, nie wieder Pufferung von Inhalt, okay, das ist natürlich Blödsinn, dass das VPN
damit was zu tun hat, wo es was bringt, ist, dass du umgehen kannst, wenn es Serien bei
dir im Land nicht gibt oder dass du beispielsweise Netflix USA verwenden kannst oder so, dafür
geht das, dass es jetzt über einen VPN irgendwie wirklich schneller laufen würde, da habe
ich so meine Zweifel, Privatsphäre für unterwegs, kann sein, muss nicht sein, wie gesagt, vom
VPN-Anbieter zum Endserver ist das Sache nicht verschlüsselt, ja, also wie gesagt, da wird
viel erzählt, wenn der Tag lang ist, ey Max, was hältst du von Storage Share, was von
Storage Share per Nextcloud, zum Beispiel, tja, ich würde es nicht machen, ich würde
meine Nextcloud Instanz im Leben nicht ins Internet stellen, würde ich nicht machen,
ich weiß nicht, also Nextcloud, also Leute, die bei mir öfters im Stream sind, die wissen
es, ich bin kein großer Nextcloud Fan, ich benutze das selbst, aber ich mag es nicht
und gerade öffentliche Instanzen von Nextcloud, ich habe beispielsweise einen Kollege auf
der Arbeit, der schwört drauf, aber der ist, der ist by the way auch Verschwörungstheorie-Man,
aber das hat damit nichts zu tun, aber passt lustigerweise ganz gut zusammen, der erzählt
mir auch jedes Mal was von Sonnenaktivität und fragt mich nicht, also typischer Verschwörungstyp,
der hat sein Nextcloud im Internet, weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie zusammenhängt, zumindest
ich würde es nicht machen, ich würde es nicht machen, das ist übrigens auch einer, der
ist die ganze Zeit während Corona mit so einem Schild rumgelaufen vor dem Gesicht und jedes
Mal wenn ich ihn was gefragt habe, ich war ja zum Glück nicht oft auf die Arbeit, aber
jedes Mal wenn ich ihn was gefragt habe und hatte eine Maske auf, was du bei uns auf der
Arbeit übrigens haben musst, wenn du auf den Flur gehst, habe ich ihn gefragt irgendwas
und da hat er immer gesagt, Max, ich verstehe dich nicht, ich verstehe dich ganz schlecht,
was natürlich alles gefaked war, der hat zumindest seine Nextcloud im Internet hängen,
ob das zusammenhängt, weiß ich nicht, aber es ist keine gute Idee, ich würde es nicht
machen, also ich finde es ist keine gute Idee seinen Nextcloud ins Internet zu hängen, wenn
ich wirklich von außen auf meine Nextcloud Instance zugreifen möchte, dann würde ich
das auf zwei Arten machen, entweder es ist nur für mich, was ja relativ wahrscheinlich
ist, wenn es ein Nextcloud ist, entweder es ist nur für mich, dann würde ich es per VPN
machen, dann würde ich mir entweder auf, was weiß ich, die meisten haben ja Fritzbox oder
sowas, was macht die Fritzbox an VPN, IPsec macht die glaube ich, ich weiß nicht ob die
Fritzbox mittlerweile OpenVPN oder Wire, wie heißt es, nicht WireShark, ich habe vergessen,
wie heißt der Kram nochmal, WireGuard, WireGuard nicht WireShark, war gerade ein bisschen verwirrt,
WireGuard, genau, da kann man das über die Fritzbox machen, man kann sich auch ein Raspberry
Pi hinstellen, OpenVPN, WireGuard oder sonst was drauf machen, aber ich würde es per
VPN machen, also wenn ich ein Nextcloud daheim stehen hätte, von der ich unbedingt von außen
drauf zugreifen muss, dann würde ich das Ganze über VPN machen, das geht natürlich
nur, wenn ich das machen will, also ich kann jetzt nicht, wenn ich mit 20 Leuten was sharen
will auf meine Nextcloud, kann ich denen nicht alle einen VPN Zugang geben, das funktioniert
natürlich nicht, über TeamViewer kannst du es auch machen, wenn du TeamViewer traust,
aber ich würde es wahrscheinlich per WireGuard machen, das nächste ist, wenn ich wirklich,
wenn ich mir wirklich ganz furchtbar gut überlegt habe, dass ich meine Nextcloud Instanz von
außen erreichbar haben will, dann würde ich es schon mal nicht auf dem Nextcloud Server,
auf dem Hetzer Server machen in dem Fall, kann man machen, wenn es wirklich komplett
von außen erreichbar sein will, aber angenommen man hat lokal eine Nextcloud laufen und möchte
wirklich, man ist wirklich sicher, dass man die von außen erreichbar machen will, für
andere und nicht über VPN, dann würde ich einen Reverseproxy davor setzen, dann würde
ich irgendwie von einem Kaddi bis zu einem Nginx Reverseproxy davor setzen, der für
mich nochmal Authentifizierung davor macht, dann gebe ich den Leuten die darauf Zugriff
brauchen ein Passwort, mache ich BasicOrd Passwort und danach nochmal Anmeldung bei
Nextcloud, ich würde meine Nextcloud nie im Leben publik ins Internet stellen, selbst
mit Authentifizierung, kennst du Mysterium, nein, kenn ich nicht, ja das freut mich auch,
das hat damit eigentlich nichts zu tun, so siehts aus, ja wir gucken uns tatsächlich
im Stream ab und zu immer mal die neue Nextcloud Version an, aber ich bin kein Nextcloud Fan,
Nextcloud wirkt auf mich auf vielen Stellen einfach immer unfertig, Preischamp sagt,
die Xbox Series S kostet nur noch, ja der Preischamp, jetzt ich muss die Gelegenheit
mal nutzen, weil gerade viele Leute da sind, eventuell benutzt einer meine Webseite hier,
habe ich auch ein bisschen Werbung für auch auf Twitter gemacht mit, ich glaube mittlerweile
800 Likes oder der Tweet, wer diese Webseite verwendet, um zu gucken wo es Grafikkarten
gibt und sowas, die Webseite gibts bald nicht mehr, die ist bald weg, die Webseite kostet
mich ungefähr 60€ im Monat, ich brauch 3 Triple-Core-Crawler und einen Web-Server
und einen, ne das war's, die Webseite gibts bald nicht mehr, erstens ist Hardware mittlerweile
naja halbwegs verfügbar und es ist immer mehr outdated, die neuen Grafikkarten sind
gar nicht drinnen und ich hab keinen Bock das zu pflegen, weil Crawler pflegen eklig
ist und die deutsche Webseiten sehr zögerlich nur unterstützen, also der bleibt jetzt noch
eine Weile on, aber die Webseite hat immer weniger Value, dadurch dass es eben weniger
aktuell ist und sie kostet mich 60€ im Monat, das wäre nicht das Problem, wenn es wirklich
top aktuell wäre und wirklich vielen Leuten noch was bringen würde, dann würde ich die
60€ bezahlen, das ist kein Ding, krieg ich paar Prime-Subs, dann ist wieder alles gut,
das ist nicht das Problem, aber ich hab keinen Bock mich selbst um die Pflege der Webseiten
zu kümmern und die sind halt relativ langsam damit und dementsprechend ist es eher, eigentlich
schon eher jebaited, wenn hier was drin steht, also die wird es wahrscheinlich nicht mal
lange geben, übrigens ich hab bald Sub-Batches, andere Frage, nutze aktuell Keypass als Passwort-Manager,
bin ich da, ja bist du, ich hab auch Keypass, Keypass ist gut, also nicht Dungeon-Keypass-Gold,
Keypass ist gut, es gibt zig verschiedene andere Passwort-Manager-Systeme, wo auch alle Leute
irgendwie drauf schwören, also jedes Passwort-Manager-System hat genug Leute, die da komplett drauf schwören,
übrigens danke Leute für die Subs, den haben wir hier am Start, Alpha Trash ist am Start,
Puzzip und der Burtonks, Prime-Subscription ja, Assif, Sixhead-Prime-Time, davor hatten
wir noch den Yule, den hab ich gar nicht gesehen und dann den Tazer, ajajaja, der Arzt hier
hat auch Subscribed, hab ich gar nicht gesehen, ich bin da immer langsam, jo, also das bist
du gut mit aufgehoben, es gibt Leute, die total auf Online-Passwort-Manager stehen,
so One-Passwort oder sowas, bin ich überhaupt kein Fan von, also gerade, ich mein man muss
sich mal überlegen, in einem Passwort-Manager, da steht der Zugang quasi so komplett zur
eigenen Identität, zum eigenen Leben drin, warum soll ich das irgendeinem Cloud-Anbieter
anvertrauen, also entweder Keypass-Lokal, Bitworn-Lokal, was auch immer, aber auf gar
keinen Fall irgendeinen Cloud-Anbieter, würde ich nicht machen, achja, und übrigens war
noch ein Tipp für Firefox-Benutzer, ich glaube in Chrome geht es mittlerweile auch, wenn ihr
zu faul seid, für Passwort-Manager, gibt genug Leute, ich kenn das, ich bin auch faul
as fuck, merkt ihr an meinem Stream-Intervall in letzter Zeit, aber ich bin der faulste
Mensch, den es gibt, wenn ihr genauso faul seid wie ich, das Mindeste, was ihr machen
könnt, wenn ihr Firefox verwendet oder Chrome, ich glaube Chrome kann es mittlerweile auch,
die haben einen eingebaut, was, das ist das jetzt neu, den kenn ich noch gar nicht, Firefox
hat einen eingebauten Passwort-Manager, man sollte wenigstens den aktivieren, man muss
nichts machen, außer sagen Use Primary Passwort, und wenn man einmalig den Firefox startet,
muss man sein Master-Passwort eingeben, danach funktioniert alles wie vorher, Autocomplete
in Formularen, automatisches Einloggen, das Mindeste, was man machen kann, ohne dass man
irgendwie was anderes macht, ist hier in ein Häkchen setzen und ein Master-Passwort vergeben
für sein Firefox, gibt es im Chrome glaube ich mittlerweile auch, also das ist wirklich
das einfachste, was man machen kann, wenn man keinen Bock auf Passwort-Manager hat,
was trotzdem halbwegs sicher haben will, ich nutze hier noch was unten, was bringt das
Keeper, das ist verschlüsselter Passwort-Safe, Zettel ist auch nicht schlecht, Zettel kann
man machen, Zettel für Passwörter ist tatsächlich viel besser als ein Ruf, weil ich meine offensichtlich,
ein Zettel kann keiner, der bei dir irgendwie einen Keylogger installiert hat, oder irgendein
Trojaner oder was auch immer bei euch auf dem Rechner hat, oder euch auch nur den USB-Stick
klaut oder was auch immer, gut, da könnt ihr euch auch den Zettel klauen, aber da hast
du keinen Zugriff drauf, also Zettel ist tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht, es ist im Prinzip alles
gut, was irgendwie so eine gewisse Barriere hat und Zettel hat halt einfach so die digital
zu analog Barriere, es kann keiner einfach von eurem Rechner auf den Zettel gucken, der
im Schrank liegt, ja gut, wenn ihr den Zettel natürlich auf der Arbeit an den Bildschirm
hängt, das jeder sieht, ich benutze Keyplus, ne One Passwort verwende ich nicht, One Passwort
ist das Zeug mit Cloud basiert, auf gar keinen Fall, geh mal bloß weg, ja also ich traue
sicherheitstechnisch Nextcloud auch nicht über den Weg. Könntest du mal zeigen, wie man das
mit Nginx macht, auf dem Raspberry Pi habe ich schon gezeigt, ich kann dir allerdings
nicht genau sagen wo, aber ich habe ein Archive, da müsstest du dir mal die Streamtitel durch
gucken, ich habe das schon mehrfach gezeigt, wie man Reverse Proxies macht, ich habe ein
Archiv von allen Streams hier auf Google Drive, da kannst du in diesem Textdokument durchsuchen
wie das Streamtitel war und dann in den jeneweiligen Ordner rein, da steht wahrscheinlich irgendwas
mit Reverse Proxy oder sonst was im Titel dann, scheint gerade sehr geschwind zu sein, aber
was anderes kann ich dir da jetzt leider nicht raten zu, vielleicht machen wir das aber demnächst
mal wieder, es ist aber nicht schwierig, naja das ist dann eher was Richtung, ja gut, machst
du, machst du, du musst dich erstmal VPN verbinden und dann kannst du auf das Produkt
oder auf das interne zugreifen, ne wahrscheinlich nicht, das ist so abartig, ihr wollt den Source
Code, also hiervon, ihr wollt den Source Code vom Preisschamp echt nicht sehen, KeyPass
ist komplett offline ja, du musst dich aber halt auch um SYNC und solche Sachen selbst
kümmern, falls du SYNCen willst, ich SYNCe by the way, mein Passwort Save nur zwischen
zwei Desktop Rechner nicht auf mein Handy, weil ich brauch meinen kompletten Passwort
Save auf dem Handy gar nicht, ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie eklig der Source Code
von dieser Website im Backend ist, aber das wichtigste Feature vom Preisschamp ist immer
noch, dass es einen Dark Mode und einen Light Mode hat, das erste und wichtigste Feature
was ich eingebaut habe, den Rest brauchen wir nicht, Rest ist Overrated, Chebaded, Outdated,
brauchen wir nicht, Dark Mode ist das wahre Feature, Dark Mode as a Service sozusagen,
ja danke für die Subs Leute, so gibt es gute KeyPass Plugins, ja es gibt einen KeyPass
für OTP, da kannst du 2 Factor Authentifizierungen drüber machen anstatt mit einem Handy, was
allerdings, muss man auch dazu sagen, den Sinn von 2 Factor Authentifizierungen ein bisschen
hinterfragt, weil 2 Factor Authentifizierungen ist ja eigentlich gerade deswegen sinnvoll,
weil du nicht auf dem gleichen Gerät beide Informationen hast, wie SYNCst du KeyPass
über 2 Rechner, ja leider mit Nextcloud, auch wenn ich Nextcloud nicht mag, aber das
war das Simpelste, weil ich schon eine Nextcloud Instance habe, ja das stimmt, wobei starke
Passwörter gar nicht so sehr darauf ankommen, dass die komplex sind, starke Passwörter
kommen darauf an, dass die lang sind, also Länge schlägt Komplexität bei Passwörtern,
also wenn ich sowas hier als Passwort habe, keine Ahnung, wenn ich sowas hier als Passwort
habe, dann machen wir nochmal ein bisschen Sonderzeichen an, hier sowas da, wenn ich
sowas als Passwort habe, dann sieht das erst einmal wahnsinnig sicher aus, das sind aber
nur 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, das geht gerade so, das geht gerade so, ich
mache nochmal ein paar Stellen weg, so, das sind nur 10 Stellen, sieht erstmal wahnsinnig
sicher aus, ist es aber nicht, wenn ihr ein Passwort habt, wie hier, keine Ahnung, Qt,
Twitch, Chat, auf meinem Channel, dann ist das hier, wenn ich es mal richtig, richtig
schreiben würde, Qt, Twitch, Chat, dann ist das hier, das eindeutig bessere Passwort,
und jetzt kommt mir keiner mit, das sind Wörter drin, das ist wurscht, also das hier ist
eindeutig das deutlich bessere Passwort als das hier, auch wenn das erst mal nicht so
aussieht, wenn ihr dann besonders cool sein wollt, dann könnt ihr beispielsweise die
Leerzeichen noch durch, fragt mich nicht, Bindestriche, andere Scores, wie auch immer
ihr setzen, wenn ihr noch ein bisschen mehr Randomness oder was auch immer reinbringen
wollt, aber das Passwort hier, ist viel viel besser als das Passwort hier, Länge ist das
wichtigste bei Passwörtern, einmal auf die Tastatur, ja einmal auf die Tastatur und
ist tatsächlich, das ist ein ziemlich gutes Passwort, leider kannst du dir das nicht merken,
Qt, Twitch, Chat, auf meinem Channel, kann ich mir merken, das heißt, das ist ein gutes
Passwort aus zwei Gründen, das erste ist, es ist sicher, und das zweite ist, man kann
es nicht merken, also, das hier ist wie lang, wie lang ist das Passwort, das ist 31 Zeichen
lang, also das ist secure as fuck, also das brute force euch keiner, mach so nebenbei,
das hier geht relativ schnell, relativ schnell, das ist falsch rum, das ist falsch rum, das
ist falsch rum, also erstens, ich weiß nicht genau, wie du auf 35 kommst, aber es ist immer
Zeichenanzahl hoch Länge, also die Möglichkeiten, kannst du ja auch Passwörter generieren,
ja der Vorteil, wenn du sowas wie Keypass verwendest, ist tatsächlich, du kannst halt
auch sinnvolle, also nicht so, was, naja, halt mir doch egal, ich will es jetzt einfach
nur zeigen, meine Güte, okay geht nicht, Keypass hat einen Passwortgenerator integriert,
dann könnt ihr euch random Sachen generieren lassen, das ist dann auch ganz gut, weil
es im Passwortmanager drin steht, ja, aber wie gesagt, Länge ist das wichtigste, das
sind 26 Zeichen hoch 31, also 26 hoch 31 und das musst du auch erstmal wissen, irgendwas
mit nochmal 43, 43 Nullen hinten dran, also es gibt sehr viele Möglichkeiten, ich habe
keine Ahnung, was das für eine Zahl ist, 7,31431701 und dann noch 43 Nullen hinten dran, das
ist viel, das ist viel, was die Bibel damit zu tun hat, bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher,
aber das ist viel, Jesus approved quasi, also die Länge ist wichtig, das heißt nicht,
dass es unsinnig ist, den Zeichenvorrat hier irgendwie aufzustocken, indem man Groß- und
Kleinschreibungen, Zahlen und so rein macht, aber Länge schlägt Komplexität bei einem
einzelnen Zeichen, Länge ist wichtiger, so siehts aus, Länge ist das wichtigste, korrekt,
wo lagert ihr eure Keypass-Datei, um auf andere Geräte wie Laptop, Tablet zugreifen zu können,
naja, wie gesagt, ich synke das zwischen meinen Desktops über Nextcloud, es gibt sicherlich
auch noch andere Varianten von Sync-Thing bis C-File oder meinetwegen auch über Dropbox,
das schöne ist, man kann theoretisch eine Keypass-Datei auch über Dropbox synken, dann
würde ich aber darauf achten, ein wirklich ziemlich gutes Masterpasswort zu haben, die
einfachste Regel bei Cloud-Geschichten ist, alles was nicht in der Cloud ist, kann die
Cloud auch nicht verlieren, oder was heißt verlieren, verlieren ist das falsche Wort,
aber ich glaube ihr wisst was ich meine, alles was ihr gar nicht in die Cloud ladet, kann
kein Problem geben, weil es nirgendswo ist, also einfach die Sachen nicht in die Cloud
bringen, ist immer noch die beste Variante, besser als Sachen abgesichert in die Cloud
bringen, am besten gar nicht in die Cloud bringen, wenn es nicht sein muss, korrekt,
Bigprane Quickmaps Leute hier am Start, wofür steht das, das sind 43 Nullen, genau, mal
10 mal 10 hoch 43, also im Prinzip 43 Nullen hinten dran gehängt.
Wie schlimm wäre das Passwort-File, wenn auf einem Passwort gesichernen Webseite gesurft
wird?
Naja, prinzipiell nicht, wenn du ein ordentliches Passwort für dein Passwort-File hast, musst
du das noch nicht machen, dann kannst du das sogar im Internet verteilen, aber ich würde
mich halt nicht darauf verlassen, wie gesagt, das einfachste ist einfach nichts in die Cloud
packen oder nichts ins Internet packen, was da nicht hingehört, dann habt ihr auch keine
Probleme, weil es könnte ja doch mal sein, ich meine, KeyPass ist so verbreitet und so
lange im Einsatz und es gab bisher wenig Stress um KeyPass, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass
nicht vielleicht doch mal in 2-3 Jahren eine Schwachstelle gefunden wird in der KeyPass
IES-Implementierung oder sowas zum Beispiel und auf einmal kannst du alle KeyPass Files
lesen.
Ist zwar sehr unwahrscheinlich, aber das Problem habt ihr dann gar nicht, wenn ihr das nie
ins Internet gepackt habt, gepackt habt, ja, ja, übrigens, eigentlich wollte ich in diesem
Stream Sachen in China einkaufen, wo wir gerade dabei sind, wir sind ein bisschen minimal
sidetracked worden.
Dein Masterpasswort hat 80 Zeichen, dann habe ich jetzt mal eine Frage an dich, wie kannst
du dein Masterpasswort merken, weil wenn du eine Passwort.txt brauchst für dein Masterpasswort
oder um deinen KeyPass zu entsperren, das ist natürlich dann auch, naja, nicht mehr
so schlau.
Hier, QuickMaps, Leute am Start, so, aber jetzt können wir eigentlich mal das machen,
was ich die ganze Zeit machen wollte, nämlich China-Chinesen-Kram einkaufen.
Der Kartoffel-Tobi ist am Start, Dankeschön für den Sub, Massive-Sub-Scription hier, benutzt
du Keyfile, wenn nein, nicht, wieso, ganz ehrlich, weil ich bisher immer zu faul war,
aber ich sollte es wahrscheinlich machen, man kann ja bei KeyPass auch mehrere Authentifizierungs-Sachen
einstellen.
Übrigens, das, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist eigentlich so das, was das Limit für
jede Security-Sache ist, Bequemlichkeit, deswegen hat es auch keinen Sinn, wenn es
so abgedrehte Passwort-Policies in Unternehmen gibt, ja, so nach dem Motto, ihr müsst alle
zwei Tage euer Windows-Passwort ändern, mindestens 48 Zeichen, mindestens 12 Sonderzeichen,
keine Zeichen doppelt, die letzten 15 Passwörter nicht wiederholen, was machen die Leute dann?
Die Leute schreien sich auf den Zettel und hängen sich an den Monitor, weil Bequemlichkeit
in dem Fall überwiegt, also weil es so krass unbequem ist, versus es richtig zu machen,
also das muss immer mit Bedacht werden, wenn man irgendwas sicher machen will, es bringt
nichts, etwas so unglaublich mathematisch unwahrscheinlich, das zu machen und so sicher
zu machen, dass es am Endeffekt keiner benutzt oder keiner richtig benutzt und jeder sagt
so nach dem Motto, ah, da lasse ich es weg oder sowas, das hat keinen Sinn, also es muss
immer im Hinblick darauf implementiert sein, dass die Leute das bedienen können und deswegen
habe ich das eben mit Firefox empfohlen, so einfache Sachen bringt am meisten, niemand
hat irgendwie großartige Einbußen dadurch, wenn er beispielsweise sagt, er benutzt ein
Masterpasswort für Firefox, das braucht genau ein Klick und du musst einmal beim Firefox
starten beziehungsweise beim ersten Auto vollständigen Passwort eingeben, fertig.
Das richtige wäre nicht unsinnige Policies, das ist richtig, aber die sehen das ja nicht
als falsch an, das ist ja das Problem, die denken ja diese Policies sind sinnvoll, weil
sie sind sicher, ja sie sind sicher, sie sorgen aber dafür, dass die Leute das komplett umgehen,
da muss man halt immer drauf achten.
Genau, das ist exakt das gleiche, Daniel Lull, danke für den Sub, das ist wie bei Backups,
wenn es nicht easy one click ist, macht es keiner, ist damit der gesamte, nee, damit
ist glaube ich nur die Formularautovervollständigung und Passwörtergeschichten verschlüsselt,
aber soweit ich weiß, ist es dann aber auch auf der Platte verschlüsselt, nämlich wenn
du beispielsweise dein Firefox Profil auf den USB Stick kopierst und in den USB Stick
einer Cloud kann keiner dran, soweit ich weiß, habe ich aber nie nachgeguckt, ob das wirklich
so ist.
Wo sind wir eigentlich stehen geblieben, vor dem Host, ich wollte Zeug einkaufen, aber
wir werden ja immer sidetracked ohne Ende bei so einem Thema, ich habe AliExpress auf,
wir waren bei RGB Glühbirnen stehen geblieben, genau, ich glaube das Thema mit RGB Glühbirnen
habe ich durch, dass eigentlich keine RGB Glühbirnen haben will, jetzt mal, Chat, Frage an euch,
zuletzt die Sache zu RGB Glühbirnen, wer von euch hat RGB Glühbirnen, oder Glühbirnen,
ist das falsche Wort, RGB Glühbirnen, Alter, RGB Lampen, wer hat RGB Lampen, ok, sind
ja schon, sind ja schon ein paar, Schreibtisch Ambilight, so, und jetzt Follow-Up-Frage,
natürlich könnt ihr mich jetzt voll in die Pfanne hauen und das falsche sagen, ich erwarte
ja auch vom Chat natürlich immer das Erwahrheitsgemäß analogisch, wir wissen ja, also der Twitch-Chat
ist ja quasi Wahrheit pur, also ich glaube, wenn alle Richter dieser Welt durch den Twitch-Chat
ersetzt werden würden, hätten wir ja natürlich eine bessere Welt, aber dementsprechend sagt
der Twitch-Chat ja auch nie was falsches, deswegen Follow-Up-Frage an euch, wer hat
nach dem Kauf von den RGB Lampen festgestellt, dass er eigentlich gar kein RGB braucht, weil
ihm eine dimmbare Lampe gereicht hätte, also wer hat sich RGB gekauft und festgestellt
eigentlich brauche ich gar kein RGB, sind auch ein paar, oder vielleicht soll ich das
anders formulieren, wer hat festgestellt, dass er zu viel RGB hat, also sprich, dass
er RGB durchaus sinnvoll findet in manchen Bereichen, aber nicht überall, obwohl er sich
zu viel RGB gekauft hat, ja, das bestätigt nicht so ein bisschen das, was ich am Anfang
auch gesagt habe, die meisten Leute wollen nämlich kaum RGB, die meisten Leute wollen
Remote An- und Ausschaltbar, oben ist ne Umfrage, advanced Mods, richtig advanced Mods hier
wieder am Start, so, gucken wir uns gleich an, weil die meisten Leute wollen ne Lampe,
die man Remote An- und Ausschaltbar, äh, Remote An- und Ausschalten kann, dimmen kann
und eventuell noch die Wärme vom, den Weißton einstellen kann, fertig, die meisten wollen
gar kein RGB, überall, genau, genau, deswegen bin ich der Meinung, die meisten Leute kaufen
sich fälschlicherweise, obwohl sie das gar nicht wollen, RGB, stellen das vielleicht
danach fest und geben viel zu viel Geld dafür aus und ich bin eigentlich da drauf gekommen
auf dieses Thema, weil es darum ging, so, was ist denn so das beste zum Einstieg in Smart
Home und so was und ich hab gesagt, viele fangen mit Lampen an, aber ich finde Lampen
gar nicht mal so sinnvoll, damit anzufangen, ja, ok, so, jetzt sagen wir mal 50-50, 50-50,
also es gibt, so viele sagen, RGB, nice, aber viele sagen, RGB braucht kein Match.
Opera geläuft ja ewig, ja, gut, ja, zumindest irgendwie bin ich deswegen da drauf gekommen,
mit Lampen und davor, davor immer was mit Steckdosen, wir sind irgendwie von, wir sind
von flashbaren Steckdosen zu Lampen gekommen, kann das überhaupt nicht mal zusammenfassen,
also falls derjenige noch da ist, der vorher was zu den flashbaren Steckdosen geschrieben
hat, das sind die Steckdosen, die ich mir zuletzt gekauft habe bei Amazon, du kannst
das hier unabhängig schalten zu dem da und dann kannst du per Webinterface drauf gehen
und, Moment, ich zeig's euch, wie das aussieht, dann kannst du per Webinterface, wenn du die
selbst geflashed hast, kannst du per Webinterface drauf gehen und dann kannst du einschalten,
Steckdose oder USB, also du kannst beides unabhängig voneinander steuern, deswegen
sind die echt cool, du kannst USB einen ausschalten hier und du kannst den Mainstrom einen ausschalten
da, wenn du das mit das Motor geflashed hast, deswegen brauchst du halt auch so China-Chinesen-Zeug,
was du flashen kannst, aufmachen und löten, das kommt drauf an, also wenn du Glück hast
und dementsprechend muss man im Vorfeld auch ein bisschen gucken, wenn du Glück hast, kannst
du die OTA flashen, hier mit, dann brauchst du einen Raspberry Pi, führst das Skript
hier aus und dann folgst du quasi einfach dem Assistent auf dem Bildschirm und der
flasht die Steckdose mit Custom-Firmware, dann ist alles gut, manche musst du aufmachen
und löten, haben wir auch sogar im Stream zusammen schon gemacht, wo ich's ein bisschen
verkackt hab, weil ich die Schraube zum Öffnen nicht gefunden hab, aber haben wir auch schon
im Stream gemacht, funktioniert, Problem ist, viele der neueren China-Steckdosen sind nicht
mehr mit einem ESP-866-Micro-Controller, dementsprechend kann man die nicht mehr flashen,
das heißt, das einfachste und das beste was man machen kann ist, in die Amazon-Bewertung
reingucken, watch out, dangerous, warum, macht der da, oh, okay, das ist, das ist nicht so
gut, okay, das ist keine so gute Idee, China-Kram halt, es ist halt China-Kram, also das Problem
hatte ich jetzt noch nicht, muss ich sagen, aber ich hab's auch nie wieder rausgezogen,
so, und man muss einfach schauen in Amazon-Bewertung, tu ja kompatible WLAN-Checken, man muss einfach
gucken, ob es hier schon Leute gibt, die das in letzter Zeit geflasht haben, so, zum Beispiel
gucken wir hier, was steht da, vom 17. September 2017, sind diese Steckdosen mit TAS-Motor
via OTA flashbar, was ist das für eine Antwort, alter low IQ, low brain Amazon Leute, was
ist denn das, also die Frage ist, die Frage ist, sind diese Steckdosen durch tu ja konvert
mit TAS-Motor via OTA zu flashen, sind nicht vorhandenen gelben Träte wirklich in Bayern
hergestellt, was, hä, okay, kommt mal hier, 19. September, leider keine Möglichkeit mehr
alternative Firmen zu flashen, dann würd ich die nicht kaufen, weder OTA noch Serielle,
ja, wenn da kein ESP mehr drin ist, dann geht's eh nicht, warum sollte man die flashen, naja,
du hast mit der, warte mal, hast du irgendwo ein Bild hier, natürlich nicht, so ein bisschen,
wenn du die standardmäßig verwenden willst, brauchst du ne App vom Hersteller und das
Ding muss nach China in die Cloud, dass es funktioniert, das ist halt die Frage, ist
man damit fein, sagt man, joa, juckt mich nicht, dass wenn mein Internet nicht geht,
oder wenn die China-Chinesen keinen Bock mehr haben, dass meine Steckdose nicht mehr geht,
dann muss man die nicht flashen, wenn man sagt, ich hab da keinen Bock drauf, dann sollte
man sie flashen und ich hab keinen Bock drauf, dass meine Steckdose nicht geht, wenn mein
Internet nicht geht und ich hab auch keinen Bock drauf, dass ich die China Cloud bin,
dass ich auf die China Cloud angewiesen bin zum Schalten meiner Steckdose, es gab doch
vor irgendwie eineinhalb Jahren mal einen größeren Ausfall bei AWS, AWS ist diese Amazon
Cloud Geschichte und da hattest du Leute, die konnten dir das Thermostat von der Heizung
nicht mehr verwenden, man muss sich das mal vorstellen, Cloud-Ausfall, gleich meine Heizung
ist nicht mehr steuerbar, das ist doch bescheuert, also, das werd ich nicht verstehen, wie man
bei so was mitmachen kann und ihr wisst, ich bin echt, was Smart Home angeht und Heimautomatik
bin ich voll dabei, seit Jahren schon, aber es gibt eine Sache, die kommt mir nie in die
Tüte und das sind smarte Türschlösser, smarte Türschlösser und das nächste, wohingegen
ich eine Abneigung hab, ist Geräte, die China Cloud Pflicht haben, so und das Problem bei
denen ist jetzt, die hab ich gekauft, da waren sie noch flashbar, mittlerweile anscheinend
ein anderer Chip und nicht mehr flashbar, deswegen useless as fuck, brauchen wir nicht mehr,
tja und die anderen Tinger findet man jetzt hier nix, deswegen man muss immer bei Amazon
ein bisschen rumgucken, ob man welche findet, wo Leute noch geschrieben haben, vor ein paar
Tagen, ja ist flashbar, das ändert sich ja auch permanent, ist so obvious gewesen, was
mir geschrieben hat, so achja und wenn du die geflashed hast, dann hast du natürlich
noch mehr Optionen danach, guck mal, zum Beispiel kriegst du ein Webinterface, nachdem du die
geflashed hast, worüber du die schalten kannst, hier ist beispielsweise USB an und aus und
hier ist Main, hier ist USB an und aus, hier ist Main Strom an und aus, ich hab's jetzt
nicht richtig beschriftet, aber der eigentliche Sinn dahinter ist nicht so sehr, dass du
ein Webinterface hast, worüber du das steuern kannst, das ist nice to have, nice to have,
was gut ist, dass du es eben ordentlich in deine Heimautomatisierung integrieren kannst,
da hast du dann hier beispielsweise Knöpfe und kannst dann sagen Licht ein und aus oder
auch Automatisierung machen, so nach dem Motto nach 22 Uhr, wenn der Fernseher ausgeht,
dann auch das Licht ausschalten oder so was in der Richtung und dafür ist es natürlich
ganz praktisch, weil mit der, mit der, mit hier der Third Party Custom Firmware kannst
du über HTTP drauf zugreifen, kannst du über HTTP steuern, kannst da aber auch über MQTT
oder andere Protokolle drauf zugreifen und das in die Heimautomatisierung einbinden.
Ja, du kannst das alles mit so einem Programm steuern, ja, kann ich, das ist übrigens nicht
mein Dashboard, das ist das offizielle Home Assistant Demo Dashboard, das hab ich jetzt
nur mal hier eingeblendet exemplarisch, wie das aussieht, das Problem ist, ich kann euch
mein Dashboard nicht zeigen gescheit, weil da zu viel, zu viel Leak ist, guck, dann würde
ich zum Beispiel auf die Map gehen, würde mich leaken und das will ich nicht, leakt,
ja, naja, 600 Zuschauer, wie richtig stonkts, ja, aber nur dank dem Host, ja, kann ich,
wieso hast du das alles in einem eigenen Netzwerk, Ordnung oder Sicherheit, hä, wie kommst du
drauf, da ich das alles in einem eigenen Netzwerk hab, ja, ich hab das alles in einem eigenen
Netzwerk, das ist richtig, vielleicht warst du mal in einem der letzten Steams dabei,
wo ich das erzählt hab, keine Ahnung, oder er hat sich gerade Hacker-Man und hat meine
Netzwerkkorpologie gescannt, ja, ja, ich hab das mal gezeigt, ja, ich hab das alles in
einem eigenen Netzwerk, also meine ganzen China-Geräte, also ich hab, ich hab mehrere Net, ich hab
mehrere Sachen, ich hab mein internes Netzwerk, da kommst du nur per Kabel rein, du musst
dich an einen Switch anstöpseln und, oder irgendein Netzwerkgerät anstöpseln per Kabel,
da kommst du ins interne Netzwerk rein und sonst nirgendwo, fertig, so, äh, dann hab
ich ein Netzwerk für, also dann hab ich ein WLAN, dann hab ich ein, äh, für, für normale
Endgeräte, Tablets zum Beispiel, Smartphones, WLAN und dann hab ich auch ein extra China-Chinesen-WLAN,
China-WLAN und das China-WLAN ist halt genau für solche Geräte gedacht, die man entweder
nicht flashen kann, oder aber halt auch nicht genau, der, dem Hersteller traut, so, und
das China-WLAN hat bei mir keinerlei Rechte, also die Geräte im China-WLAN dürfen nicht
miteinander kommunizieren, ich hab da doch sogar mal, hab ich da nicht sogar mal ein
Bild zugemacht?
Netzwerk, guck mal, ich hab da sogar, ich hab da sogar ein Bild mal gemacht von meinem
Netzwerk, ich weiß aber nicht so genau, ob das, ja hier, ja genau, genau, genau, internes
Netzwerk, das ist, das hier ist internes Netzwerk, intern, internes Netzwerk hier dran, ähm,
alles hier an den Switch, dann ist ein Router dazwischen mit Firewall, dann hab ich zwei
WLANs für IOT-Geräte und ein Client-WLAN für Tablets, Smartphones und sowas, ja und
dann das ganze hier nochmal, dann, gut da hab ich eine Fritzbox für Decktelefone dran,
genau, ja, so ist das bei mir getrennt und alles was in diesem IOT-WLAN drinne ist, hat
bei mir halt keinen Zugriff aufs Internet, das einzige was erlaubt ist, in dem IOT-WLAN
ist, raus per MQTT auf einen MQTT-Server bei mir intern und NTP auf den Router, sonst
ist nix erlaubt, also die Geräte dürfen sich die Zeit abrufen und die dürfen ihre
Daten an einen vorher festgelegenen MQTT-Server schicken, das war's, mehr dürfen die nicht.
Kennst du schon die Preflash-Tasmotor-Geräte bei Ali?
Ja, die wollte ich mir jetzt nämlich, das ist gut das du sagst, die wollte ich mir jetzt
nämlich in extrem auch mal angucken, was es da aktuell gibt, ja, weil die Chinesen sind
auch schon auf den Trichter gekommen, die haben gesagt, hey, manche Leute wollen eben
nicht unsere komische China-Firmware haben mit China-Cloud, sondern das Motor, es gibt
Geräte die schon mit Custom, naja gut, man kann kaum noch Custom-Firmware sagen wenn
sie vom Hersteller mit ausgeliefert wird, aber es gibt Hersteller mittlerweile, beispielsweise
hier Atom, die sind da bekannt für, die haben Geräte die sind schon Preflashed damit, wobei
in dem Fall sieht man halt, es ist viel zu teuer, das lohnt sich überhaupt nicht, das
sind zwei Stück, nein, es sind vier Stück, ok, das Foto ist einfach nur doof, das Foto
ist einfach nur doof, also Preflashed 46 Euro ist auch ein bisschen teuer, aber immer
noch günstiger als beispielsweise so einen Shelley-Plug, das ist quasi die nächste Alternative,
die Shelley-Plugs haben eine ziemlich gute, ich weiß nicht, ob es Open Source-Firmware
ist, aber die kann man flashen, aber die haben eine ziemlich offene Firmware drauf an Autokollen,
die sind auch nicht schlecht, aber da kostet es halt, da kostet es halt, ich hab sie irgendwo,
da kostet halt ein 4er Pack 83 Euro und das ist halt echt ein krasser Unterschied, hier
bezahlst du 39 oder teilweise nur 29, je nachdem, was für welche 4er Packs du kaufst
und deswegen lohnt sich das ja auch preislich, wenn ich mir was kauf, was alles das macht,
was ich will, von dem ich das weiß, dass es das macht, was ich will und wo ich auch keine
Bedenken habe, dass sie nach Hause telefonieren und die relativ offen sind, dann müsste ich
jetzt halt 83 Euro ausgeben oder ich kauf mir beim Amazon Prime Day mal irgendeine China-Chinesen-Steckdose
für 30 Euro im Angebot und dann bekomme ich für quasi einen Drittel, weil Amazon kostet
ja der Versand auch nichts, dann bekomme ich für einen Drittel quasi, oder sagen wir mal,
ich bekomme 12 Steckdosen, wo ich hier nur 4 dafür bekomme, das ist natürlich schon
was. So und bei den Chinesen, hier ist es halt 46 Euro preflashed mit dieser Firmware,
ich habe es noch nie gekauft, ich weiß nicht, ob das sinnvoll ist. Preislich liegt es so
in der Mitte, es ist nach wie vor China-Chinesen-Kram und die können mir ja viel erzählen, von wegen,
dass es ein Original-Tasmotor ist. Natürlich kann ich danach noch mal selbst drüber flaschen
und so, dass das geht. Da müsste man mal gucken. Leider ist es gerade auf AliExpress, wenn man
nicht genau guckt, teurer als früher, das liegt nicht nur an Mehrwertsteuer und Gedöns, sondern
dass die auch gerade allgemein bisschen, weiß ich, Teilemangel haben, weil man vieles, also in
AliExpress auch nicht mehr viel billiger bekommt als hier, was komplett entgegen meiner Erfahrung
der letzten Jahre ist. Ja, anscheinend gibt es da gar nicht so viel preflashed. Ja, das ist
tatsächlich was, das könnte man machen, wobei man halt mal gucken muss, was der Versand nach
Deutschland kostet. 14 Tage Versand. Wenn man Glück hat, kommt es dann gar nicht direkt aus China,
aber anscheinend schon. So, in den Einkaufswagen, was wird es denn kosten mit Versand? Da waren
noch günstige ZigBee-Steckdosen, ja, aber die sind wahrscheinlich nicht Tasmotor geflasht. Die hat
es einfach nur angezeigt. Guck mal, die hat es wahrscheinlich einfach nur angezeigt aus
irgendwelchen. Hä? Tasmotor mit ZigBee geflasht? Die haben da ernsthaft einen ESP32 mit ZigBee
drin? Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen. Das ist bestimmt China. Das stimmt nicht. Die
haben das bestimmt einfach Copy-Paste-Fehler gemacht. Das ist bestimmt Copy-Paste-Fehler.
Übrigens, so viel günstiger ist es gar nicht. Das ist einfach nur blödsinnig. Die haben
Copy-Paste, die haben blödsinnig Copy-Paste. Und ZigBee kannst du außerdem eh schalten,
ohne Custom-Firmware und auch ohne China-Cloud. Das heißt, brauchst du da sowieso nicht. Das ist
Blödsinn. So, und Versand würde das Ganze jetzt kosten? Kostenloser Versand? Okay,
46 Euro, das liegt halt genau in der Mitte. Ja, das liegt zwischen den Shelley-Dingern,
wo du halt mit Versand 86 Euro bezahlt und zwischen 30 Euro Viererpack China Zeug bei Amazon. 46 Euro,
das könnte man machen. Wobei ich die Dinger halt jetzt Feature-technisch auch nicht so geil finde.
Das ist einfach eine Steckdose mit einem Schalter, den du WLAN-technisch schalten kannst. Die andere,
die ich euch hier gerade gezeigt habe, die kann den Verbrauch messen darüber, mehr oder weniger
genau. Also man sollte jetzt hier keine hochwissenschaftlich genauen Dinge erwarten,
aber so der Spur nach kommt es hin. Wenn ich da meinen 2000 Watt Heizlüfter dran hänge und
anschalte auf der ersten Stufe, dann sagt das irgendwie 900, was weiß ich, 98 Watt oder so,
dann das kommt schon ungefähr hin. So, und dann zusätzlich kann es halt auch noch den Verbrauch,
den Verbrauch dann sich merken. Ja, und deswegen finde ich diese Steckdosen gerade so cool. Du
hast die Möglichkeit zu gucken, was es aktuell für Leistung braucht, was es an Strom verbraucht hat.
Du kannst USB und Strom gleichermaßen, also unabhängig voneinander schalten. Das finde ich
eine super Kombination. Ich bin froh, dass ich mir das gekauft habe, weil anscheinend die aktuelle
Ausgabe davon ist nicht mehr flashbar. Was Banggood soll, was soll ich suchen auf Banggood? Alphawise.
Gibt es nicht. Alpha4 Games, Alphawise gibt es ja anscheinend nicht. Aber die Suche auf
diesen China Seiten ist eh höchst fragwürdig. Da fragst du dich eh, warum findet die Aliexpress
Suche nicht. Guckt euch mal diese Seiten an. Ich persönlich habe ja die Vermutung, es gibt
ein, guckt euch diese Seiten nebeneinander an. Ich habe die Vermutung, es gibt ein chinesisches,
aber alles auf die gleiche Größe. Guckt euch diese Seiten nebeneinander an. Ich habe die Vermutung,
es gibt ein chinesisches, staatliches Ministerium für Webdesign oder irgendwie sowas. Und die haben
gesagt, alle China Shops müssen so aussehen. Das ist, guckt mal, also die Ähnlichkeit ist
wirklich nicht zu übersehen. Da hat gesagt, da hat die chinesische Regierung gesagt, wir können
uns nur einen Webdesigner leisten. Ihr müsst jetzt alle das gleiche Design machen. Alibaba ist ja
die Business to Business Plattform, die Aliexpress Business to Business Plattform. Oder man könnte
sagen, Aliexpress ist die Endkunden Plattform von Alibaba und Alibaba ist Business to Business.
Eher von Amazon abgekupfert, auch, auch, aber trotzdem. Es ist, es ist, es ist, naja,
Amazon macht weniger Wind drum herum mit Gutscheincodes und und Pop-ups und so. Bei Amazon
steht es mal an jeder Ecke, machen sie Prime, machen sie hier, aber diese Seiten sehen nach
Scam aus. Wenn ihr jemand seid, jetzt überlegt euch mal, ihr habt noch nie was in China bestellt
und ihr geht auf so eine Seite drauf, ihr denkt doch, ihr werdet gescampt. Ihr denkt doch, was ist
denn das? Das sieht, das sieht aus, das sieht aus wie Scamas. Ihr bestellt da noch im Leben nichts.
Nee, nee, null. Die HG, sie sieht alles so aus. Sieht alles so aus. Aber es funktioniert. So,
genug gelabert, ich wollte ein paar Sachen einkaufen. Zeig mal, ich hab doch hier meine,
meine Liste. Also, ja, was ich bei Aliexpress gucken wollte, ist tatsächlich sowas in der
Richtung, was hier schon auf ist. Äh, Moment. Denkst du nicht, dass Leute, die hier bestellen,
eher technisch bewandt sind? Erst mal schon. Also, ich glaube, die meisten Leute, die in
Deutschland bei Aliexpress bestellen, die sind technisch bewandt. Die sind auf der Suche nach
günstigen Technikkram. Die wollen sich beispielsweise einen Microcontroller kaufen oder so was. Ja,
denke ich schon. Aber trotzdem, ich glaube, immer mehr Leute haben es mittlerweile kapiert,
dass man in China ganz gut bestellen kann, dass die Sachen da teilweise auch nicht wirklich
schlechter sind. Zumal es halt einfach viele China-Dinger hier auch eins zu eins zu kaufen gibt.
Ähm, ich glaube, mittlerweile kaufen da auch viele nichts. Ursprünglich ja, aber mittlerweile,
glaube ich, gibt es genug technisch nicht so versiert hinter das Kaufen. Aber die einzige
Daseinsberechtigung von Wish, nein, Wish ist ja, weil viele Leute zu dumm sind, bei Aliexpress zu
bestellen. Also, das ist die einzige Existenzberechtigung für Wish, ist, dass die
Leute sich nicht trauen oder zu blöd sind oder es nicht checken, bei Aliexpress Banggood DH Geld
oder was nicht alles zu bestellen. Weil den Kram, den du bei Wish bekommst, ist genau,
wahrscheinlich noch schlechter, wahrscheinlich noch schlechter, ist genau der gleiche Kram,
den du bei Aliexpress bekommst. Nur noch schlechter wahrscheinlich. Die haben das schlechte von
Aliexpress dann auch noch da. Bei Aliexpress hast du immerhin die Chance, wenn es nicht
ordentlich funktioniert, dass du dein Geld wieder kriegst. Und ich muss ja mal sagen,
es wird ja immer so gesagt, ah, wenn du das in China bestellst, da siehst du dein Geld nie
wieder, siehst du dein Produkt, ich muss sagen, meine persönliche Erfahrung bisher mit dem Support
bei Aliexpress sind besser als mit dem deutschen Paypal oder mit dem EU Paypal Support. Das kann
man bei Wish jetzt nicht so unbedingt sagen. Wish ist im Prinzip, du wirst gescampt und du hast
gelitten danach. Bei Aliexpress, ich hatte bisher erst ein Problem und das wurde wirklich super
gelöst. Ich habe mal was bestellt, ich weiß am besten keine Ahnung, was das war, wahrscheinlich
irgendwelchen Elektronikkram. Ich weiß nicht mehr. Ich habe bei Aliexpress was bestellt und die haben
mir einen Code geschickt, einen Senderverfolgungscode. Ich habe nachgeguckt über zwei Wochen, weil die
gesagt haben, hier Senderverfolgung ist jetzt auf dem Weg. Ich habe zwei Wochen lang immer
nachgeguckt, immer gesagt, der Senderverfolgungscode funktioniert nicht. Ich bin mal, wobei ich jetzt
gar nicht mehr sicher bin, ob er nicht funktioniert hat oder ob immer das gleiche Dastand so nach dem
Motto, Waren ist auf dem Weg zum Flughafen. So, da habe ich gesagt, also Leute, funktioniert nicht,
klappt nicht. Und dann haben die mir noch einen Code geschickt. Neuen Code, haben sie, ah, sorry,
sorry, ah, wir haben uns vertan, es ist auf dem Weg, es ist auf dem Weg. Hier, hier neuer Code,
hier neuer Code, habe ich den neuen Code genommen, habe es eingegeben, war genau der gleiche Code wie
das erste Mal. Die habe ich, habe ich halt wirklich, ich weiß nicht, ob die mich versucht haben zu
scammen oder ob die, ob die selbst nicht gecheckt haben. Zumindest war es genau der gleiche Code wie
das erste Mal und es, er hat auch, er hat nicht funktioniert. Gut, daraufhin bin ich zu Aliexpress,
da kannst du in deinem Kundenkonto bei Aliexpress kannst du auch so ähnlich wie, wie bei Paypal,
bei Paypal Käuferschutz, gehst du auch bei Aliexpress in dein Kundenkonto und sagst hier
Beschwerde zur Bestellung oder sowas und dann ist es komplett andersrum als bei Paypal. Bei Paypal,
wo ich Probleme hatte, wo ich auch mal ein paar, also ich habe bei Paypal auch schon öfters
Käuferschutz gemacht, hat gut funktioniert, aber einmal richtig Probleme, weil die einfach nicht
darauf reagiert haben, also der andere Shop. Sondern bei Paypal ist es so, du musst Gott und die
Welt da beweisen, dass du da nichts verkehrt gemacht hast und sonst wie und dann kriegt der
Shop irgendwie ein riesen Ultimatum von, haben wir nicht irgendwie 30 Tagen, wo die sich melden
können und sonst wie. Und hier bei Aliexpress war das ganz einfach. Ich habe das aufgemacht,
die sind in diesem Beschwerdefall, habe gesagt hier, zweimal angefragt, ist immer noch nicht
auf dem Weg, jetzt ich habe zweimal die gleichen Code gekriegt, nicht verschickt, ging auch nur
irgendwie um, was weiß ich, 45 Euro oder so. Und was hat Aliexpress gemacht? Aliexpress hat
gesagt, okay wir schreiben den Shop an und die melden sich bis morgen. Der Shop hat sich auch
bis morgen gemeldet und hat gesagt, ah sie haben sich vertan, ob ich noch ein bisschen Geduld habe
und ich habe dann einfach einen Tag nicht auf das Support Ticket bei Aliexpress geantwortet.
Ich habe einfach einen Tag nicht geantwortet und was ist passiert? Ich habe das Geld wieder
bekommen. Die haben geschrieben so nach dem Motto, okay, weil sie nicht responded haben, gehen wir
davon aus, es war nicht erfolgreich, hier haben sie ihr Geld wieder. Also das ist komplett umgedreht
von dem, wie ich es erwartet habe. Ich wollte die scammen mich jetzt übelst und Aliexpress hat es
genau umgedreht gemacht. Bei Paypal musste ich sonst was machen, Fotos von der zerbrochenen
Class-Tür hinschicken und sonst wie und ja ich habe das da auch wirklich gekauft und hier und
guck und bei Aliexpress einfach nur einen Tag nicht reagiert. Ich wollte ja sogar noch was
darauf antworten und einen Tag später, oh hier hast du dein Geld wieder. So easy. Also ich kann
wirklich sagen, ich habe bei Aliexpress nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht, was das angeht. Nur 45 Euro,
naja nur 45 Euro ist nicht so sonderlich viel für das, was ich da bestellt habe. Ich habe,
ich weiß nicht mal was es war, aber Elektronikkram und Elektronikkram kannst du easy 45 Euro ausgeben.
Ich hätte mich jetzt nicht gefreut, wenn ich gescampt worden wäre, es wäre aber auch nicht
so wahnsinnig schlimm gewesen, aber das was ich jetzt sagen wollte, ich wurde noch nie wirklich
gescampt, so dass ich mein Geld da verloren habe. So, jetzt wollte ich ja übrigens was einkaufen,
was wollte ich, genau, also ich bin ja immer noch dabei ein RGB Türschild zu bauen. Das habe ich
euch jetzt 85.000 mal gezeigt, aber für alle die es nicht kennen, zeige ich das nochmal. So was hier
will ich mir bauen. Das ist nicht nice, das ist nice oder? Richtig massiv nice. Taugt Aliexpress
ja, ich finde Aliexpress gut. So, also sowas finde ich halt, finde ich halt nice. So und die
Hausnummer habe ich mir schon bestellt. Was ich jetzt noch brauche sind LEDs. So und ich wollte mir
eigentlich ein WS, ne, ne, ne, SK6 RGBW mit 144, 144 LED pro Meter kaufen. Warum die? Also das sind
LED Strips. Ich werde da wahrscheinlich zwei, eins oder zwei Strips für brauchen. Die, das sind so
ungefähr 20, 25 Zentimeter und da muss ich halt den RGB Strip hier innen drinne lang legen,
dass das gescheit funktioniert. Was kommt? Keine Anzeige von den Nachbarn oder jemand Grundeinkommens,
ey das wird mich in Deutschland auch nicht wundern, wenn da irgendwie sowas kommt in
der Richtung. Wie viel FPS hat deine Hausnummer dann mehr als durch RGB? Das ist ja die grundsätzliche
Frage erstmal, wie viel FPS du überhaupt sehen kannst mit deinem Auge und wir sind uns ja alle
einig, dass es 12 FPS pro Auge sind. Das heißt 24 zusammen und das kriege ich damit hin. Das
ist ja allgemein bekannt, maximal 24. Du siehst nur 6 FPS wegen schlechter Auge. Ja, F mit Brille 25.
Aber warum? Weil das Licht dann irgendwie gebogen wird oder was? So und warum die? Ganz einfach,
weil es RGBW ist. RGBW heißt es ist eine rote, es ist eine grüne, es ist eine blaue und es ist
eine weiße LED drin. Das heißt der Weißton ist viel schöner und ich gehe mal davon aus er hat
auch RGBW, weil ansonsten musst du weiß mischen durch RGB. Hat den Nachteil, braucht ein bisschen
mehr Strom und wird ein bisschen wärmer. So wie viel bezahle ich denn hier? Wie viel bezahle ich
denn hier bei Amazon für? Gut, IP Nummer ist egal. Also diese IP Sache ist Wasser und Staubschutz.
IP 30 ist im Prinzip, kannst du vergessen, wenn da Wasser dran kommt, RIP. IP 67 ist, glaub,
staub, mehr oder weniger staubdicht und nicht nur Spritzwasser, sondern ich glaube sogar direkte
Wassereinstrahlung geschützt. Braucht man aber nicht, braucht man aber nicht, weil es kommt ja
ins Gehäuse, also ich kann die normalen kaufen. Ihr seht doch nicht, die danach werden eine ganze
Ecke, naja geht so. Sind aber auf jeden Fall schwieriger zu verarbeiten, weil die noch mal
so Plastik oben drüber haben. Was welcher Controller? Ich werde den gleichen Controller verwenden,
den ich für mein ganzes Eigenbau RGB Zeug zum habe. Zum Beispiel ich habe, ich muss euch jetzt mal auf
Twitter zeigen. Ich habe ja ein bisschen RGB Zeug schon gepostet auf Twitter in letzter Zeit. Oh Gott,
Twitter, geh mir nicht auf den Sack. So, wir haben zum Beispiel einmal diese Lampe hier. Sag mal,
warum ist denn Twitter so langsam gerade? Das lädt ja überhaupt nicht. So, wir haben die Lampe,
ne das ist was anderes. Oh meine Antenne, die Antenne ist übrigens immer noch da. Ich habe
jetzt richtig guten Empfang immer. Wo ist meine Lampe? Wo habe ich die Lampe gepostet? Ah ja,
in dem Serverraum Video sieht man das auch. In dem Serverraum Video sieht man das auch mit der Lampe.
Hier. Welche Distro? Das ist Manjaro mit E3WM. So, einmal habe ich so eine RGB Lampe mit Gehäuse
aus dem 3D Drucker gebaut und an Silvester, nicht Silvester, an Weihnachten habe ich ja auch noch,
da muss ich zurückscrollen zu letztem Jahr. Habe ich ja auch noch selbst gebaute Fenster,
ähm, ich war nicht selbst gebaute Fensterrahmen, ich habe einen Rahmen gebaut, so mit Diffusor
fürs Licht, wo man ein RGB am Fenster hat. Ja, ich finde mein eigenes Zeug nicht mehr.
Hier, das ist noch, das ist noch ohne Diffusor. Da hat, da war die RGB, da waren die RGB Sachen,
habe ich noch direkt zum Test mal ans Fenster gemacht. Mittlerweile ist da so ein Rahmen mit
Diffusor drüber, dass man nicht mehr die einzelnen Bildpunkte so einfach sieht. So und diese zwei
Dinger laufen beide als Controller, das war übrigens der Feuerwerkeffekt, der, also das
habe ich nicht standardmäßig an, weil das ist ein bisschen nervig. Wenn du das die ganze Zeit am
Start hast, wenn ich mir vorstelle, ich würde hier am Rechner sitzen und hätte das die ganze
Zeit abends neben mir laufen, das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel des Guten. Also sowohl dafür,
als auch dafür, als auch für meinen RGB Weihnachtsbaum, den ich glaube ich gar nicht
gepostet habe, aber so ein eigener RGB Lichterkette für Weihnachtsbaum, da verwende ich beides mal
für GitHub WLED, da verwende ich WLED zum Steuern, WLED zum Steuern, genauso sieht das
Webinterface davon aus und als Controller habe ich einen D1 Mini, sowas da. Und wisst ihr,
was das Beste daran ist? Das ist alles günstig as fuck. Guck mal, so ein D1 Mini kostet 3,50 Euro,
ja sogar bei Amazon 10 Euro für 3 Stück und das Zeug ist wirklich günstig. Der Controller
kostet irgendwie 3 Euro, 3, 4 Euro und dann brauchst du halt noch ein Netzteil und du brauchst
halt die Leisten, also beziehungsweise die Strips. Und dann kannst du das über das Webinterface
steuern. Mal kurz schauen, ob ich irgendwas gerade angeschlossen habe, dass ich da ins Webinterface
mal gehen kann. Nee, ich habe nichts angeschlossen, nehme ich gerade alle aus. Okay, ja, so sieht
es aus. Und dann über ZigBee mit, nein WLAN, nicht ZigBee, die Dinger hängen ja eh am Netzteil,
also können die auch über WLAN. ZigBee hat ja nur den Vorteil, wenn es batteriebetrieben sein soll.
Wie hast du denn das Aquara Thermometer geflasht? Kannst du den empfehlen? Ja, kann ich empfehlen,
ist eine richtig coole Geschichte. Für alle, die nicht wissen, was ich meine, ich meine das hier,
das finde ich jetzt relativ schnell. Das habe ich jetzt noch nicht vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
gepostet. Ich habe mir einen Thermostat geholt oder einen Thermometer. Thermometer ist doch
ein besserer Begriff. Fürs Bad, wasserdicht oder spritzwasserdicht zumindest von den
China-Chinesen. Mal gucken, da gucken wir mal, was das bei Aliexpress jetzt gerade kostet,
das da. Das, was Jesus said, was Jesus said geguckt. Oh, so sieht das aus. Ups, so sieht das aus. Die
Batterieanzeige unten ist übrigens fail. Was trending in Deutschland selbst, weil ich klick da
jetzt nicht drauf. Ich klick da jetzt nicht drauf. Ich klicke Twitter, ich klicke Twitter Trends
nicht an. Wer weiß, wer weiß, was da wieder abgeht. Das ist Monkathos. 500 Viewer, ja,
wegen dem Host. Genau, also dieses Thermometer, das ist ein, mal gucken bei Amazon, das ist ein
Xiaomi. So, mal kurz Thermometer, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie es hieß, wie es hieß, das da.
Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit, das ist auch genau das gleiche. Also die Dinger sind nicht sonderlich
teuer und die habe ich geflasht und zwar, genau, also das da unten ist die Luftfeuchtigkeit und
das da ist die Batterie. Und normalerweise hält die Batterie vielleicht ein halbes Jahr. Also der
Hersteller sagt, die Batterie hält ein Jahr. Wenn der Hersteller sagt, die Batterie hält ein Jahr,
hält die in der Regel bei den China-Herstellern ein halbes Jahr bis ein Jahr. Und bei mir ist
es jetzt schon fast ein Jahr im Einsatz und es hat erst 90 Prozent. So, und ich habe Custom
Firma drauf gemacht, das ist ziemlich einfach. Man geht auf GitHub, sucht sich das passende Projekt
dazu raus. Was man braucht ist einen Raspberry Pi, einen neueren Raspberry Pi mit Bluetooth.
Und dann nimmt man dieses Projekt, geht auf seinen Raspberry Pi drauf und dann macht man das,
was hier steht. Du machst die Seite auf, auf deinem Raspberry Pi im Browser,
kannst auch bei X-Formating machen oder so. Dann suchst du Geräte. Wobei, du musst es theoretisch
noch nicht mal von einem Raspberry Pi aus machen, du musst es von einem Gerät machen,
das Bluetooth kann. Du musst es mit einem Gerät machen, was Low-Energy-Bluetooth kann.
Das muss kein Raspberry Pi sein. Ich habe es aber über den Raspberry Pi gemacht. Haben wir
zusammen gemacht im Stream. Habe ich im Stream irgendwo geflasht. Ist auch im Archiv alles
drin. Dann flashst du das mit Custom Firmware. Da kannst du dann auch einstellen, ob du Uhrzeit
drauf haben willst oder nicht. Uhrzeit kann ich euch nicht empfehlen, weil die Uhrzeit geht
sau schnell out of sync und das Ding hat weder irgendwie NTP Support noch irgendwie eine Uhr
eingebaut oder sonst was. Lasst euch einfach Luftfeuchtigkeit anzeigen und Temperatur und
Batteriestand. Das reicht. Ihr müsst unbedingt runterstellen, dass das alle 5 Sekunden oder
so seine Werte verschickt. Das ist der eigentliche Grund, warum das mit Originalfirmware im China
Auslieferungszustand, warum das so schnell Batterie verliert. Ich habe eingestellt, dass
das glaube ich nur alle 2 Minuten oder so die Werte schickt und das hält halt viel viel
länger. Und mal ganz im Ernst. Also 2 Minuten reichen doch voll und ganz aus für Temperatur
und Luftfeuchtigkeit im Bad. Brauche ich wirklich einen 5 Sekunden Update? Ist das wirklich
notwendig? Brauche ich wirklich alle 5 Sekunden ein Update für die Temperatur und die Luftfeuchtigkeit
im Bad? Also ich denke nicht. Ich bin der Meinung, es reicht auch alle 2 Minuten. Gibt
sicherlich Leute, die brauchen das, dann sollen sie es halt so hinstellen. Manche wollen es
bestimmt in Echtzeit haben. So nach dem Motto Websocket Verbindung noch darauf auf, dass
es permanent rüber pumpt. Macht was ihr wollt. Ich habe es auf alle 2 Minuten eingestellt.
Genau und das habe ich hier mit dieser Firmware geflasht. War total easy. Es gab nur eine
Sache, worauf man aufpassen muss. Man durfte glaube ich nicht die Verbindung trennen zwischendurch.
Also man sollte das wirklich direkt daneben legen, weil ich glaube, wenn du zwischen dem
Flaschen an einem falschen Moment abgebrochen hast, hast du es gebrickt. Was nicht weiter
wild ist, wie gesagt, der Kram kostet 7 Euro oder sowas auf Amazon. Und jetzt gucken wir
mal, was der Kram bei AliExpress kostet. Wahrscheinlich ist er auch gar nicht so viel billiger.
AliExpress Thermometer. Okay, doch, die sind bei AliExpress eine ganze Ecke billiger.
Hier kriegst du 4 Stück. Kostet aber Versand. Ist aber trotzdem günstiger. Hier kriegst
du 4 Stück für... Hä? Was ist das denn wieder für ein Chebat? Was ist das für ein AliExpress
Chebat? Hier steht 12,97 Euro. Und hier steht jetzt was von... Ah, 12,97 Euro. Okay, ich
habe nichts gesagt. Ich habe mich irgendwie verlesen. Also 12,97 Euro. Aber es kostet
ja noch... Es kommt ja noch... Es kommt ja noch 4 Euro Versand obendrauf. Also sagen
wir mal, es kostet 13 Euro. 17... 17 Euro durch 4. 17 durch 4. Ah, du bezahlst trotzdem
nur die Hälfte. Du bezahlst trotzdem nur die Hälfte wie bei Amazon. Also in dem Fall,
das würde sich... Wenn man das braucht, wenn man das gerne hätte, würde es tatsächlich
lohnen, das über AliExpress zu kaufen. Vielleicht hat man Glück und guckt ein bisschen rum
und es ist auch günstiger. Hier kostet der Versand nur... Die sind nicht blöd. Die sind
nicht blöd. Guck mal. Guck mal. Die Einzelne lohnt sich sogar mehr. Nee, lohnt sich nicht,
ist ein bisschen teurer. Ja, und es ist da bis zum 11. Oktober. Das ist okay. Ja, und
das ist jetzt so, früher konntest du bei AliExpress bestellen und du musstest dir nie Gedanken
machen, dass es irgendwie beim Zoll hängen bleibt. Also die China, die chinesischen Chinesen,
die haben das echt gut drauf gehabt. Also ich hatte nie Probleme beim Zoll mit AliExpress.
Wo ich immer Probleme hatte mit dem Zoll, ist aus den USA bestellen. Die Amis kriegen
das einfach nicht richtig hin. Die Chinesen können das eindeutig besser. Und ich habe
jetzt eine Sache bestellt. Dieses Jahr erst bei AliExpress für irgendwie 60 Euro oder
60 Euro, das waren diese 2 Hausnummern, hat auch ohne Probleme funktioniert. Aber AliExpress
hat jetzt ein neues Feature. Du bezahlst jetzt standardmäßig Mehrwertsteuer für Deutschland,
wenn du nach Deutschland bestellst. Also früher konntest du dir dann hier auch einstellen,
was weiß ich, Versand nach Dingswährung, sonst wie. Da musstest du keine Mehrwertsteuer,
da konntest du Chibane. Aber ob das damals schon okay war, fraglich. Aber jetzt musst
du, was ja auch okay ist, was ja auch vollkommen legitim ist, sollte ja auch so sein. Und dann
schicken die das los und wie gesagt, es ist bei mir bis jetzt auch nichts beim Zoll gelandet.
So und in dem Fall wird sich das tatsächlich lohnen. 10 Tage Lieferung aus China, bezahlst
du die Hälfte wie bei Amazon? Finde ich okay, kann man machen. Ja und wenn man ein bisschen
rumguckt, hat man vielleicht auch die Chance, das auf anderen Seiten zu finden, das dann
entweder Versand umsonst ist oder das Thermometer. Man darf sich übrigens bei diesem Xiaomi Zeug
nicht verwirren lassen. Xiaomi ist nicht sowas wie Sony, doch man kann es vielleicht so
ein bisschen mit Sony vergleichen oder mit Samsung. Mit Samsung kann man es glaube ich
ganz gut vergleichen, weil die stellen diese Dinger gar nicht selbst her. Dieses Xiaomi
ist eigentlich nur so ein Oberüberlabel und das fasst ganz viele Hersteller zusammen.
Deswegen haben die auch so viele Dinger. Von Staubsauger, Roboter, bis Handy, bis Thermostat.
Es gibt ja, sagt mir mal was, was Xiaomi nicht hat. Chat, fällt euch irgendwas ein? Was haben
die nicht? Also mir fällt so pauschal Twitch Emotes. Also mir fällt pauschal wirklich
wenig ein, was die nicht haben. Brot, Autos. Bei Autos bin ich mir gar nicht mal so sicher.
Ob die nicht sogar Autos mittlerweile haben. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall nicht viel, was
die nicht haben. Die Webseite, wo man die Verfügbarkeit von Grafiken hat, preischamp.org. Aber wie
gesagt, die Seite wird es wahrscheinlich immer so lange geben. Leberkäs haben die nicht.
Ja gut, das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass die kein Leberkäs haben. Bei allem anderen
bin ich mir aber nicht so sicher. Dementsprechend haben die auch oftmals ziemlich merkwürdig
konkurrierende Geräte. Fünf verschiedene Sensoren für das Gleiche, fünf verschiedene
Unterkategorien, die das Gleiche machen. Das ist ein bisschen verwirrend. So, hier sind
es drei Stück. Hier gibt es zehn Stück plus. Zwanzig Stück plus. Wait a minute. Für was
genau bezahle ich denn hier jetzt? Vierzehn Euro für was? Für eins und dann mal zehn
oder was? Ach hier. Doppelpack, Dreierpack. Ah ne, viel zu teuer. Viel zu teuer bei Banggood.
Viel zu teuer. Das kostet eins und vierzehn Euro. Lull. Das ist ja sinnlos. Das ist ja
sinnlos. Also in dem Fall Banggood hat sich nicht gelohnt. Lohnt sich nicht. Versand an
Vereinigte Staaten. Ne ne ne ne. Versand. Guckt euch mal an. Guckt euch mal auf dieser
Seite das Dropdown dann und guckt euch das Dropdown hier oben an bei Aliexpress. Das
ist doch einfach genau das Gleiche. Es kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass das nicht der
gleiche Typ designt hat die Seiten. Das ist doch einfach genau das Gleiche. Euro. Scale
Killer sieben Monat reiche für den Sub. Huge Subscriptions. Also das lohnt sich schonmal
gar nicht. Bei Banggood. Wie siehts bei Banggood aus? Vier Stück. Was? Oh das ist billig. Boah
das ist billig. Ach das ist eins. She baited.
So das ist doch wieder. Guck mal. Da haben die vier drauf. Da siehst du mal. Da sind
sie trickreich. Da sind sie wirklich trickreich. Man denkt sich so vier Stück 6,99. Normaler
Preis wird ja auch passen. Bam. She baited. Stimmt nicht. Zack. Ja dann ist Aliexpress
tatsächlich das günstigste. Weißt es nimmt sich eigentlich nichts. Hier ist halt kein
Versand und bei dem anderen schon. Na ja. Du kannst einfach nachinstallieren. Das ist
überhaupt kein Ding. Du kannst einfach nen MQTT Addon bei Home Assistant mitinstallieren
lassen. Home Bridge kann man irgendwie auch integrieren. Hab ich aber nicht gemacht weil
ich keinen Home Bridge in Apple Automatisierungs Smart Kram verwende. Die haben jetzt aber
hat she baited hier. Da lohnt sich das nicht. Dann kaufen wir das bei Aliexpress. 4 Stück.
Jetzt kaufen. Chipping gibt es auch gar nicht mehr so viel. Da haben sie auch das jetzt
angepasst. Früher hattest du bei Aliexpress immer 7,8 verschiedene Shipping Dinger zur
Auswahl. Ist jetzt nicht mehr so. Aha guck mal hier gibt es noch mehr. Warum kostet das
jetzt mehr? Die Chinesen verwirren mich. Was? 53 Cent. Ok das gibt es wieder alles 100 Mal
zu kaufen hier. Das ist jetzt 4 Stück. Ah nee. China. Das ist halt auch so ein Ding bei Aliexpress.
Aliexpress ist halt eher Marketplace. Das kann durchaus sein dass du 20 Händler findest
die den gleichen Kram anbieten. Also nicht unbedingt den erst besten nehmen. Hier wird
man jetzt irgendwie 30 Cent oder so sparen aber das lohnt sich nicht. Was hast du schon
gekauft? Nur den Kram hier. Also nicht mal den habe ich bestellt. Wie viel gibt es denn
hier? Wie viel gibt es? 10 Stück. 10 Stück für 28 Euro. Also 8 Euro. Guck mal das lohnt
sich überhaupt nicht. 10 Stück sind. Nee. Ich kann nicht rechnen. 10 Stück. 1 kostet
dann 2,90 Euro. Das wird sich tatsächlich lohnen. Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Ah mit Versand. Versand 3 Euro. Ok also 29 Euro. Also 32. 32 durch 10. Sehr schwierig
kann man ja dem Kopf. 3,2. Ja da wäre ich geneigt dazu das zu bestellen. Ich meine für
30 Euro kannst du dann nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen. Wozu 10? Warum nicht? Diese Fragen
immer im Chat. Wozu? Als wenn es darum geht. Eigentlich brauchst du nichts davon. Du brauchst
doch ein Klo. Es reicht auch ein Loch in der Erde. Aber 10 Stück warum nicht? Alles über
eins ist bloat. Nein. Mindestens Dreierpacks bestellen. Ihr kennt meine Philosophie. Nie
Einzelsachen bestellen bei Elektri Geschichten. Immer mindestens Dreierpacks. Wie schreibst
du die Daten vom Thermometer in Home Assistant? Sehr gute Frage. Ich glaube das haben wir
sogar im Stream zusammen programmiert. Ich habe im Bad einen ESP hier dran hängen. Nämlich
da dran. Der hier der gerade on ist. Am USB von dieser Steckdose. Hängt einen ESP32
dran. Der ESP32 hat permanentes wie nennt man das so? Empfang. Bluetooth Low Energy.
Guckt was die Geräte zu broadcasten. Und der empfängt Bluetooth Low Energy für Temperatursensor
und für dieses Thermometer. Und für meine Waage. Die drei Sachen macht er. Waage, Bluetooth,
dann habe ich eben Miflora. Einen davon verwende ich als Temperatursensor für meinen Kühlschrank.
Die sind eigentlich zum Überwachen von Pflanzen gedacht. Kann man aber wunderbar auch als
Temperatursensor in Kühlschrank legen. Ich habe im Hof drei Stück, die sind tatsächlich
für Pflanzen. Einen im Kühlschrank. Und eine Waage über Bluetooth. Und das Thermometer
über Bluetooth. Und ich habe einen ESP32 im Bad hängen, der das alles empfängt und
dann über WLAN per MQTT an meinen Home Assistant schickt. Ja. So siehts aus. Das ist übrigens
auch ein Punkt, was ich an dieser ganzen Heimautomatisierungsgeschichte äußerst nice finde. Man lernt was dabei.
Es muss einem aber auch liegen. Also ich muss sagen, bisschen gebasteln muss einem schon
liegen. Zumindest mit dem Ansatz, wie ich das mache. Ich mache ja viele Do It Yourself Geschichten
und Home Assistant ist halt auch was, was es eher befürwortet. Man bastelt gerne. Ja,
man lernt was. Ich habe ich habe sehr viel über Mikrocontroller, Elektronik Sachen
gelernt, seit ich da selbst dran rumbasteln. Ich habe aber auch schon die ein oder anderen
Sachen abgefackelt. Ich mein, das beste Beispiel dafür ist ja immer noch. Moment. Müsste
ich mal bookmarken. Das beste Beispiel dafür ist ja immer noch das hier. Clips, All Time,
All Time. Wo ist das Smoke Clip? Smoke. Habt ihrs gesehen? Alter Twitch, please. Habt ihrs
gesehen? Da rauchts oben. Hier. Pass auf, pass auf. Und hier rauchts gleich. Also ich
habe schon die ein oder anderen Sachen abgefackelt. Und da kann ich übrigens gar nichts dafür,
dass ich das abgefackelt habe. Da kann ich überhaupt nichts dafür. Das ist der China-Chinesen-Spannungswandler,
der der Meinung war, er geht kaputt und anstatt kaputt zu gehen, lässt er einfach zwölf
voll durch anstatt 3,3. RIP. Kann auch der Nachteil sein, China Zeug zu kaufen. So, das
kauf ich jetzt. Bäm. Einkaufswagen. Einkaufswagen ansehen. Hab ich hier noch drinnen? Preflash.
Warum ist denn das jetzt noch billiger? Äh? Eben stand doch da was von 28 Euro. Ach das
ist das falsche, was ich gekauft hab. Lul, Alter. Meine Güte. Giss weg. Das da will
ich haben. Das ist das falsche. So, Einkaufswagen. So, Einkaufswagen ansehen. Jetzt aber. Jawoll.
New User Bonus. Nee, nee, nee. Aber ich hab nen Account. Perfekt. Ja. Wunderbar. Begrenzte
Menge verfügbar. Morgen gibt's nix mehr Leute. Perfekt. So. Also, haben wir den Kram schon
mal eingekauft. Was brauch ich denn noch? Ich muss mal kurz in meine Einkaufsliste gucken.
Eine Pumpe für meinen Katzenbrunnen, der ist kaputt. Ja. Aber das kauf ich mir lieber
auf Amazon. Muss ich mal kurz schauen. Äh, ich hab hier für meine Katz. Was übrigens
richtig nice ist, wer auch Katzen hat, kann ich das nur empfehlen. Wubpad. Die Mode wird
viel zu oft vergessen hier. Wubpad 2. Ähm, ich hab hier, ich glaub, das sieht dem ähnlich
zu dem, was ich da hab. Zumindest Katzenbrunnen ist das die beste Erfindung. Die stehen da
komplett drauf. Also, alle, die ich bisher hatte, fanden das super. Ich glaub, ich hab
so welche hier. Ich hab auch China-Noname-Kram. Aber das ist super. Also, die Katz find das
geil. Ich hatte mal so einen hier, so einen aus Keramik, sowas hier in der Richtung. Den
fanden meine erste Katze fanden den super. Die anderen beiden jetzt finden den kacke,
weil das Wasser hier so fließt und nicht, und nicht quasi runterfällt. Mit oder ohne
RGB. Macht das Ding Geräusche, wenn das richtig aufgefüllt ist, macht es kaum Geräusche,
dann hört man es nicht viel. Ding exklusiv aus der Gießkanne. Ja, meine Katz hat es auch
am liebsten, wenn ich den Wasserhahn anmache. Zumindest ist die Pumpe kaputt bei dem einen.
Ich wollt mal gucken, ob es da welche gibt. Ja, sowas hier in der Richtung. Alter, dafür
krieg ich ja neun Brunnen. He doesn't know, he lacks critical information. Ich hab gedacht,
das gibt's billiger. Für den Preis kann ich mir neun Brunnen kaufen. Ja, was ist das denn?
Warum soll ich quasi für den Brunnen das gleiche ausgeben wie für eine Pumpe? Ist
der Katzenbrunnen auch mit dem Smart Home verbunden? Was meint ihr Leute? Ratet mal.
Ist mein Katzenbrunnen mit dem Smart Home verbunden? Noch nicht morgen schon. Korrekt.
Chillflick an Recht. Das ist eine Steckdose, die ich schalten kann. An und aus. Also man
könnte sagen, der Smart Home ist, der Katzenbrunnen ist mit dem Smart Home verbunden, wenn aber
auch nur mit ner remote schaltbaren Steckdose. Ich weiß nicht, ob das zählt. Also irgendwie
schon, aber irgendwie auch nicht. Hoffentlich der Katzenbrunnen ist mit einer Gegensprechernage
verbunden. Und was soll der dann machen, wenn es anruft? Wenn es klingelt? Boah, das ist,
das sehe ich jetzt nicht ein. Katzenbrunnen kostet 19€ und Pumpe kostet 12€. Das ist
irgendwie, widerstrebt mir das. Auf der anderen Seite ergibt das schon irgendwie Sinn, weil
das einzige was an diesem Katzenbrunnen was kostet ist wahrscheinlich die Pumpe. Der Rest
ist einfach billiges Plastik, was 30 Milliardenfach hergestellt wird und dann irgendwann mehr
landet als Mikroplastik da rumschwimmt. Ich soll da 5 Voltpumpe gucken. Ist das 5 Volt?
12 Volt. Der 2 Watt sagt ja nichts. 2 Watt ist ja die Leistung, das kann ja auch von
sonst was kommen. Das können auch 48 Volt sein oder so. Davon kaufe ich keine 10 Stück,
davon kaufe ich einen. Ich glaube den Angaben da drauf nicht. Ok, das kaufe ich jetzt nicht,
ist egal. Muss ich woanders mal gucken. Vor allem Wechselstrom. Das kann sein, ich glaube
es auch nicht, aber das kann sein, meine Pumpe im Garten braucht auch sowas ganz scheppes.
Irgendwie 14,8 Volt AC und sowas. Wo ich bis heute nicht so genau weiß warum. AliExpress
hat auch sowas, da guckt man bei AliExpress. Deck Deal. Ultra ruhiger mini bürstenloser
DC USB. USB? Tatsächlich USB. Was ist das? 5 Volt, kann man das nicht groß machen? Wo
stürzt denn hier? 5 Volt DC 4,8 Watt. Die Sache ist halt die, ich weiß nicht ob der
da reinpasst. Und warum kostet das nichts? Ich kann es mal aus Frankreich schicken lassen
oder aus China. Ah ok, das kostet nichts, weil es aus China 4,60 Euro Versand kostet.
Das ist ja auch eine geile Taktik. Ok, ich kriege es umsonst in China, bezahle aber 4,60
Euro Versand. Ich kann es mir auch aus Italien bestellen, da kostet es 5,18 Euro, aber der
Versand ist kostenlos. Alles klar. Seems legit. Das ist China-Chinesen Logik. Guck mal, man
kann es sogar runter stellen. Ach ok, dann kommt es erst am 12. November. Aber dann kostet
mich das ganze Ding, wenn ich bis am 12. November noch brauche, 2,82 Euro. Ich bin ja fast geneigt
das auszuprobieren, ob das wirklich für 1 Cent und nur Versand ankommt. Ich bin ja fast
geneigt dazu das auszuprobieren. Auch immer, es geht noch billiger. Aber dann bis zum 26.
Oktober. Und nochmal hier, Super Economy, 2,17 Euro nur. Bis zum 25. November. Das probiere
ich aus, ob das mich wirklich nur 2,18 Euro kostet. Das bin ich mal gespannt. Ok, mit
dem Einkauf, Einkaufsverein. Übrigens Leute, soll ich euch mal was richtig Nices, ok das
Kalender 2021, was richtig Nices zeigen. Und zwar brauchen wir Kalender 365 EU. Kalender
Schulferien meinetwegen. Gibt es nicht eine Seite mit einem schönen Kalender? Was zum
ist das, das ist das dann hier. So, Kalender, jawoll, den da, den brauchen wir. So, wir
haben jetzt, Alter, was ist das hier? Ok, exquisite. Also, wir haben jetzt glaube ich,
was ist denn heute, warum habe ich ja oben eigentlich kein Datum eingeblendet. Wir haben
den 27. September. Also, wir sind jetzt da. Wir rechnen mal die Woche raus. Ich habe das
Virus nicht, ich habe zum ersten Mal einen Corona-Test gemacht vor einer Woche und ich
bin doppelt geimpft. Ich habe aber gedacht, vielleicht ist Corona, ist es aber nicht.
Wann kommt das Video mit, Herr Endpunkt, ich muss es noch ein bisschen schneiden, habe
ich noch nicht gemacht. Entweder, wahrscheinlich am Dienstag, wahrscheinlich am Dienstag Nachmittag.
Aber nur, wenn ich heute noch ein bisschen was schneide da dran. Also, was ich sagen
wollte, folgendes. Lassen wir mal die Woche weg. Gehen wir mal von aus, es wäre Oktober.
Ich muss jetzt noch Oktober arbeiten. Also, arbeiten ist ja, viele denken, Max, laber
nicht, du arbeitest ja eh nicht. Kann man so sehen. Aber ich arbeite vier Tage die Woche,
siehst du ja. Aber ich muss trotzdem diese vier Tage die Woche dann auch arbeiten. Zumindest
ich muss jetzt Oktober arbeiten und ich muss November arbeiten. Aber ich habe auch noch
ein bisschen Urlaub übrig und dann bin ich den ganzen Dezember nicht da. Also, nicht
auf der Arbeit. Ich habe den ganzen Dezember wieder Zeit, komplett YouTube, Twitch und
online Streaming zu machen. Das bedeutet, nachdem ich ja nur vier Tage die Woche arbeite,
sind das eigentlich nur noch. Lasst mal kurz rechnen. 1, 2, 3, 4. Also, 8. Dann sind es
16, 17, 17. Chat, merken 17. Äh, was ist das hier? Sind das Feiertage? Sind aber doch
in Hessen keine Feiertage. 11. November. Bus und Beta sind in Bayern. Äh, das ist bei
uns auch kein Feiertag. Ok, 17 Tage. Und das hier sind nochmal 4, 8, 16, auch 17. 34 Tage.
Das heißt, ich muss noch 34 Tage, also einen Monat dieses Jahr arbeiten und dann ist vorbei.
Dann ist es geschafft. Wobei das gar nicht mal stimmt. Ich habe ja noch 3, 4 Tage Rest
oder ob das heißt wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich gehe ich schon hier so irgendwie in dem Dreh.
Ja, richtig huge Poggers. Advent Co. Haben wir nicht genug Cobol gemacht letztes Jahr
schon? Abstimmung für Cobol an Weiner. Ja, meinetwegen, macht eine Abstimmung. Macht
eine Abstimmung. Das heißt ja nicht, dass ich mich an die Abstimmung halten muss. Macht
meinetwegen eine Abstimmung. Ja, ist gut. Mach eine Abstimmung. Hast du da eine Vertretung
oder fällt im Dezember nicht mehr viel an? Ich habe das extra so geregelt, dass im Dezember
nichts mehr ist. Weil ich mache das ja die letzten Jahre über schon so. Ähm, dass ich
Dezember nicht da bin. Ich mache das bestimmt schon seit 6, 7 Jahren so, dass ich Dezember
immer komplett weg bin. Und wir haben das jetzt so geplant, dass wir machen auch kein
neues Release im Dezember und sowas. Also wir machen einfach nichts, was ich hauptsächlich
mache und dann passt das ganz gut. Und ja, die restlichen Sachen übrig bleiben, macht
dann irgendjemand anderes. Oder, um es realistisch zu betrachten, wahrscheinlich bleibt es liegen
und ich mag es nicht. Nächstes Jahr. Wie wäre es mit Fortran? C++, ne ne ne ne ne. C++
machen wir nicht. C++ machen wir ganz bestimmt nicht. C++ machen wir schon viel zu oft, wenn
wir irgendwelche Microcontroller-Geschichten machen. Ich hasse C++. C++ ist die schlechteste
Programmiersprache aller Zeiten. Dann mache ich lieber Cobol. Dann mache ich lieber Cobol.
Das heißt schon was. Und jetzt fragt mir keiner, warum ist C++ schlecht. Das dauert wieder
zwei Stunden, bis ich mich darüber ausgelassen habe. Du hast also vier Tage Woche und das
elf Monate im Jahr. Genau, so könnte man das sagen. So könnte man das sagen. So, ähm,
dann machen wir mal weiter. Ich hab nebenbei mein Auge auf die Abstimmung, was da raus
kommt. Genau, davon, die hab ich witzigerweise offen gehabt, davon wollte ich mir auch noch
ein paar kaufen. Und zwar, was man damit machen kann, sind halt diese Lampen bauen. Und ich
finde die Dinger echt cool. Find ich wirklich nice. So. Algol68, was kommt als nächstes?
Adda oder Abab? Wie heißt dieses Ding von SAP nochmal? Wie heißt diese SAP? Ist das
Abab? Es ist Abab. Ne, ne, ne, das machen wir nicht. Das machen wir nicht. Tja, Chet,
jetzt habt ihr euch ein bisschen selbst jebaited. Cobalt kann ich machen, C++ kann ich machen,
aber Lochkarten, wie soll ich das im Jahr 2000, fast 22 machen? Ihr habt euch jetzt in irgendwas
rein jebaited, was ich nicht machen kann. Oder vielleicht habt ihr mich doppelt jebaited.
Ihr wusste, dass ich das nicht machen kann und habt es deswegen gewählt. Fragt bei
IBM an. Ne Lochkarten haben wir tatsächlich nicht mehr. Wir haben noch ziemlich viele
alte IBM Rechner, aber keine Lochkarten. Ja, 16 mal 16 LED Matrix, die sind Poggers, die
will ich haben. Aus China. Wir kommen mal da. Das lohnt sich überhaupt nicht aus Polen
zu bestellen. Aus China ist es billiger und der Versand ist... Moment. Was kostet mich
in der Kram bei Amazon D? 16 mal 16. Zwei Wochen länger juckt mich nicht. Guck mal, bei
Amazon 29,99 28,99. 29. 42 Euro. WTF. Ok, Lochkarte, alles klar. Ihr habt euch jebaited
im Chat vorbei. Tja, dann würde ich doch mal sagen, dann ist es jetzt an der Zeit. Wann
ist die Lieferung? 20. Oktober. Ja, das geht ja. Das geht ja. Was haben wir denn für Optionen?
Ja, ist gut. 43 Euro Versand mit DHL. Versand mit AliExpress. Und dann ist es nur ein Tag
früher da. Und dann ist es... Was ist denn das? Das ergibt ja absolut gar keinen Sinn.
Was für ein Netzteil kommt in die Stehlampe? Du meinst da rein? 5V. 5V Netzteil. Wenn ich
mich jetzt nicht total vertue. Ich glaube 5V. 5V TCR. 5V Netzteil. Davon kannst du die
LEDs und den Microcontroller betreiben. Gut, 5 Stück. Bäm. Einkaufskorb. Oder wird es
dann teurer? Nee. Da, Care, Einkaufskorb. Pumpe für 1 Euro. Nein, nein, nein, nein,
nein. Den Versand habe ich so nicht ausgewählt. Die jebaiten mich, den Versand habe ich nicht
ausgewählt. Den habe ich auch nicht ausgewählt. Ich habe ausgewählt Saving für 2,17 Euro.
Die jebaiten mich hart. Bei AliExpress. Das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Das ist Scam-Arst.
Guck, was ich ausgewählt habe ist China, Versand, Super Economy. Das habe ich ausgewählt.
Nicht das. Diese alten jebaiter Chinesen. Also bei AliExpress musst du wirklich auf
Zack sein, dass du nicht gescampt wirst. Ja, so nicht. So nicht. Weg. Lass mich doch nicht
gehen. Ja, der Rest passt. Jebaited, ja. Richtig, richtig jebaited. Kannst du deinen 3D-Drucker
noch empfehlen? Einen würde ich mir nicht mehr kaufen. Also das ist ein i3 Mega. Das
ist immer noch ein ganz cooler Drucker, aber ich glaube, da gibt es mittlerweile Nachfolger
für gleiche, hier der da, ungefähr gleicher Preis, aber automatisches Leveling. Und automatisches
Leveling ist einfach nice. Da musst du ja an keinen Schrauben rumstellen. Den würde
ich nicht mehr kaufen. Ist okay, aber ich würde jetzt, ich würde mal was Neues kaufen.
Der ist ja auch schon jetzt ein bisschen älter. Okay, nice. Also nächstes. Was brauchen wir
sonst noch? Das mit der Pumpe habe ich geguckt. Ja, genau, was die LED-Strips kosten, wollte
ich noch gucken bei den Chinesen. Also LED-Strips. Wo hatten wir den Kram? LED-Strips. Genau,
SK6812 RGBW. Wichtig ist das W, weil ich will auch eine weiße LED dabei haben. Und,
ne, nicht 12 Volt, 5 Volt. Genau, 144. Das ist ja noch teurer als bei Amazon. Das lohnt
sich aber nicht. Das lohnt sich ja, oh. Das ist doch beschiss, oder? Da stimmt, da stimmt
doch was nicht. Daub das. Da stimmt doch was nicht. Kostenloser Versand. Die wollen mir
ernsthaft erzählen. Ich bekomme für einen Cent den Streifen. Sus, aber richtig Sus.
Das glaube ich nicht. RGB. Mal gucken, was passiert, wenn ich den Einkaufswagen mache.
Äußerst Sus, das glaube ich nicht. Ladenrabatt. 15 kaufen und 2% Rabatt bekommen. Ok, das
heißt, ich bezahle dann unter einem Cent, oder was? Moment, es ist nur Userbonus. Aber
trotzdem, 4,94€, das kann nicht sein. Das ergibt keinen Sinn. Die haben sich... Ach,
das sind 30. Das sind 30. Den brauche ich. Ok, ok. Da sind wir jetzt aber schon in anderen
Preisregionen. Das sind 30 LEDs auf einen Meter. Ich meine, ein Cent ist immer noch
billig. Aber sowas ist bei Amazon auch günstiger. Guck mal, die haben gar nicht 30. 30 LED.
Das ist ja noch teurer. Manchmal verstehe ich den China Kram nicht. Also ich bin wirklich
geneigt, das einfach mal Just For Fun zu bestellen, um zu gucken, ob das wirklich ankommt. Guck
mal, hier kostet er einen Euro. Ja gut, das ist New User. Ich muss mich da einloggen und
gucken. Aber, also, irgendwie, irgendwie suspekt. Irgendwie ist mir das suspekt. Ok, brauchen
würde ich D hier, einen Meter. Ich könnte mir theoretisch auch gleich zwei Meter bestellen,
weil die kannst du einfach durchschneiden. Also LED-Streifen kannst du einfach durch...
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding, kannst du durchschneiden. Das lohnt sich aber nicht wirklich, zwei
Euro oder so. Was hat denn dieser Typ hier drin in dem Video? Der hat doch auch irgendwas
verlinkt. Hausnummer, Schild, LED-Strip. Ok. Hier, das empfiehlt er. Moment, der hat 300
LEDs. Ok. Leute, das ist zu übertrieben, oder? Meint ihr, es macht Sinn? Meint ihr, es macht
Sinn, hier einen LED-Strip mit 300 Schatz 144 LEDs einzubauen? Ich meine, guckt mal,
wie klein das ist. Also das ist eh schon... Ich bezweifle, dass man das großartig erkennt.
Ja, mehr LED ist mehr gut. Wie gut sind solche Diffuser? Ey, die sind ok. So ähnliche habe
ich auch. Nicht exakt die, aber so ähnliche habe ich auch. So welche in der Richtung
habe ich auch. Sind die elastisch oder warum? Ah, die sind elastisch. Die gehen glaube ich,
durchaus. Ich habe welche, die sind ähnlich zu denen hier. Kannst du den Link zu dem 1-Cent-Ding
mal posten? Ja, mache ich. Wenn du eingeloggt bist, kannst du ja mal schauen. Wenn du eingeloggt
bist, kannst du ja mal schauen, ob das bei dir auch nur 1-Cent-Ding kostet. Ja, aber
dann bestelle ich das doch mal. White, L, G, B, C, W. Ey, ich habe es schon im Korb
drin. Ja, dann gucken wir mal, ob das für 1-Cent-Ding ankommt. Aber das ist nur User-Rabatt.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich 4 Euro bezahlen. Aber 4 Euro für den 1-Meter-LED-Strip sind auch
absolut in Ordnung. Kannst nichts sagen. Wie gesagt, bei Amazon bezahlst du da deutlich
mehr für 30-LED-Strips. Guck mal, der Kram kostet hier auch. Ich meine, 30 auf 1 Meter
ist ein bisschen wenig. Das ist so für Passives zu Ambient Lighting oder so ist das sicherlich
ganz cool. Aber wenn du damit aktiv irgendwas machen willst mit Animationen, dann ist das
eher nichts. Okay, da haben wir das bei AliExpress gekauft. Nice. So, einfach stimmt, ich wollte
mal gucken, was der... 300, das ist doch schon echt zu viel. Moment, warum kostet das bei
ihm auch nur 14... Ah, 0,5. Das heißt, ich brauche 2 Stück. Und das ist aber definitiv
zu dumm. Boah. Aber ich bezahle doch keine 24 Euro Versandkosten dafür. Also man muss
sagen, 24 Euro Versandkosten ist eigentlich das, was ich früher erwartet hätte, dass
Dinge aus China kosten. Aber nachdem ich ein paar mal... Also nachdem ich selbst angefangen
habe, in China zu bestellen, habe ich gelernt, dass Bestellen in China der Versand billiger
ist, als von Deutschland nach Deutschland zu versenden. Deswegen sehe ich das nicht,
einer 24 Euro für ihn zu bezahlen. 4,70 Eingelogged. Aber trotzdem sind wir noch billig. Ist wirklich
günstig. Das hier weniger. Okay, dann suchen wir mal nach 300 LED. Moment, was hatte der
hier auf? WS. Ja. Das sind die ganz billigen. 5 Meter Rollen. 300 LED. Ja, 300 LED pro Meter.
Oder wie? Oder was? Ach, keine Ahnung. Zu viel RGB auf einmal. Halt ich nicht aus. Ich
kaufe jetzt was anderes. So, was brauche ich denn noch? Zeig mal hier. Shop. iPhone 11
Case. Ja, das muss ich jetzt nicht im Stream suchen. Ach ja, ich wollte mein Friedhofsprojekt
wiederbeleben. Wiederbeleben ist das falsche Wort. Was ist der Unterschied? Ich vermute
mal die Weißfarbe. Ich glaube, das ist warmes Weiß, neutrales Weiß, kaltes Weiß. Wie sieht
es eigentlich mit dem Zoll aus, wenn man in China bestellt? Kommt das meistens problemlos
durch? Ja. Wenn du auf den USA bestellst, hängt das immer im Zoll. Wenn du in China bestellt,
hatte ich bisher, ich persönlich, kann ja nur von mir ausgehen, aber ich habe schon einiges
bestellt in China. Noch nie. Ein einziges Mal ist es im Zoll hängen geblieben und ich
habe dieses Jahr auch schon bestellt nach diesen ganzen neuen Regelungen und es ist
nicht hängen geblieben. Du musst aber jetzt mehr an Steuer bezahlen. Was auch vollkommen
okay ist. So. Was wollte ich jetzt machen? Ja, ach genau. Ich wollte mein Friedhofsprojekt
wieder, wie gesagt, wiederbeleben ist das falsche Wort, mal endlich ordentlich funktionsfähig
bauen. Wer sich jetzt fragt, was ist mein Friedhofsprojekt? Da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen
ausholen. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich davon mal Fotos gemacht habe. Ich glaube
nicht. Aber ich werde euch das mal kurz erzählen. Und zwar mein Opa und meine Oma, die leben
ja beide nicht mehr. Und die liegen auf dem Friedhof, der ist ungefähr eins bis zwei Kilometer
weg. So ungefähr. Und mir schwebt schon seit längerer Zeit ein Projekt vor, dass ich dort
in das Grab auf dem Friedhof ein Bodenfeuchtigkeitswassermesser rein mache, der mir dann wireless überträgt,
ob man wieder auf den Friedhof gehen muss und dort gießen. Das heißt nicht, dass ich
da sonst nicht hingehe. Aber gerade im Sommer ist es nicht immer so klar. Man muss auch
teilweise alle zwei, drei Tage hingehen. Und das habe ich ausprobiert. Das funktioniert.
Was ich gemacht habe ist folgendes. Ich habe mir einen ESP-Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor gekauft.
So was da. Wichtig ist, die da sind Schrott. Diese mit zwei Fühler sind Schrott, weil
die messen die Bodenfeuchtigkeit über Spannung hier dazwischen. Das heißt, das Material löst
sich mit der Zeit auf. Man braucht diese Dinger. Da habe ich am Start. Kein Problem. Also ich
habe mir so einen Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor geholt. Hier oben habe ich einen Schrumpfschlauch
drum gemacht. Hier oben habe ich einen Schrumpfschlauch drum gemacht, dass es nicht nass wird. Aber
kein Problem. Das glaube ich würde es auch so aushalten. So ich habe ich einen Schrumpfschlauch
dicht drum gemacht, dass nichts passiert und habe das in die Erde gesteckt. Da dran habe
ich einen ESP32. Einen ultra low power ESP32 Controller dran. Ich nehme den da. Der braucht
bloß 10 µA im Deep Sleep. Das ist wenig. Und daran habe ich dann 1200 mAh Akku dran
gehängt. Das ist kein Problem, weil dieses Board hat schon einen Akku Charger und Ladecontroller
und einen Schutzcontroller mit drauf. Das hat auch alles funktioniert. Jetzt ist natürlich
die Preisfrage, wie übertrage ich Daten. Ich lasse für alle, ich muss euch nicht fragen,
der Chat hat schon gespoilert. Wie übertrage ich die Daten 1 bis 2 km heim? Gibt es zwei
Varianten wie immer das Ganze? Macht doch Solarbetrieb. Das funktioniert nicht richtig,
weil während er an ist, braucht er ja schon ein bisschen Strom. Also während er an ist
und was verschickt, braucht er so 200 mAh würde ich sagen. Also es gibt zwei Varianten
wie man das machen kann. Das erste ist und das naheliegendste eigentlich auch, wäre
das mit einer SIM-Karte zu machen. Es gibt super billige, das haben wir ja auch schon
im Stream angeguckt, es gibt super billige IoT SIM-Kartentarife. Das Problem mit der
SIM-Karte ist, ja klar, es kostet was. Es ist, genau, das nächste was das Schreibs hat,
der Verbindungsaufbau ist relativ langsam, dementsprechend muss das Gerät relativ lange
an sein. Also das kann durchaus sein, dass es dann, was ich 20 Sekunden brauche, bis
es verschickt ist. Was ziemlich lang ist, 20 Sekunden, wenn du an einem Akku läufst
und möglichst 2-3 Jahre Akkuladung haben willst. Und das ist aber auf jeden Fall eine
sinnvolle Möglichkeit. Es kostet ein bisschen Geld, es ist nicht der Wahnsinn. IoT SIM-Karten
sind wirklich billig, das gibt es dann für 2 Euro im Jahr oder 5 Euro im Jahr oder sowas
für irgendwie 5 MB zu übertragen. Das ist wirklich günstig. Aber das ist das nächste,
du brauchst ein Modul, du brauchst ein Modul für SIM-Karten. Und das ist dann schon gar
nicht mehr so einfach. Da habe ich keins. Ich habe einen ESP mit einem SIM-Karten Modul,
aber da müsste ich erstmal, doch, doch, gibt es, gibt es, gibt es alles. Habe ich auch
schon dran gedacht, habe ich auch schon dran gedacht. So, und das habe ich alles zusammengebaut
und habe das nicht mit SIM-Karte gemacht, sondern ich habe es über LoRa gemacht. LoRa
ist ein Protokoll mit ziemlich niedriger Bandbreite, aber recht großer Reichweite. Also, du musst
ja bei so einem Sensor plus, nee LoRa ist 833, 830 MHz oder sowas, du musst ja nicht
viel übertragen. Im Endeffekt, was muss man übertragen? Ja, irgendwie ein paar Bytes.
Lass es mal 5, 6 Bytes sein, die du übertragen musst. Du kannst meinetwegen die Temperatur
noch zusätzlich übertragen oder 68 MHz, ja, irgendwie sowas. Aber du musst, also um
den Bodenfeuchtigkeitsstand zu übertragen, das sind 2, 3 Bytes, was du da brauchst, wenn
überhaupt. Ein Byte wahrscheinlich reicht. Von 0 bis 100. Ein Byte reicht, ja. Also,
ein Byte ist genug um den, also ich muss nur ein Byte übertragen. Ein Byte alle, übertragen,
ein Byte alle 4 Stunden. Das ist nicht sonderlich viel, was ich da an Bandbreite für brauche.
Das habe ich über LoRa gemacht. Wie gesagt, LoRa ist ein Protokoll, was nicht hohe Bandbreite
hat, aber ziemlich weit geht. Und das habe ich ausprobiert, das habe ich ausprobiert
und das hat funktioniert. Ich habe es aber nie auf dem Friedhof vergraben, meine Konstruktion,
ich habe das dann in einem IP67 oder was auch immer Gehäuse gemacht, dass es wasserdicht
ist und das hat funktioniert. Ich habe es aber nie verbuddelt dort, ich habe es immer
nur ausprobiert, ich habe es in den Rucksack und habe gepinkt, ich habe permanent gepinkt,
ich habe es in Powerbank in Rucksack, habe permanent gepinkt und bin einfach vom Haus
weggelaufen, bis es ausgegangen ist. Und das ging eine ganze Weile, das ging sogar noch
weit hinter den Friedhof, die Übertragung, also ging an die 2km die Übertragung nach
Hause. Ich habe einfach gepinkt und habe dann auf dem Handy geguckt, ob der Ping daheim
angekommen ist. Ich habe es dann so gemacht, wenn der Controller daheim was empfangen hat,
hat er es publisch zu einem MQTT Server und ich habe geguckt vom Handy, ob es angekommen
ist. Also ich habe immer gesehen, ich habe immer gesehen, ob der Ping quasi zurückkommt.
Ich habe das über LoRa gemacht, das funktioniert, ich habe das aber nie fertig gebaut. Ich habe
einen eigenen LoRa Empfänger gehabt, den habe ich gebaut mit einem TT-Go, ich glaube T-Beam,
kann das sein, nicht T-Bone, T-Beam. Mit sowas da in der Richtung habe ich das gebaut, mit
so einem Controller, die wirklich sehr nice sind, muss man sagen. Ich habe da aber eine
größere Antenne noch dran gemacht, die wirklich sehr nice sind, weil die gibt es mit Display,
das ist nicht so wild, habe ich ein eigenes Display dran gemacht, aber die gibt es theoretisch
auch mit Backup-Batterie und GPS, was ziemlich beknackt ist, weil für meine Basis-Station,
das ist viel zu teuer, das musste in China kaufen. 20€, guck mal hier, AliExpress, wo
wir gerade beim Thema sind. Vielleicht ist der T-Beam aber auch nicht aktuell. Die LoRa
Chips kosten aber was. Die LoRa Chips sind aber die teuren Sachen, das liegt gar nicht
so sehr an dem eigentlichen Controller. Die LoRa Chips kosten, du musst Lizenzkosten
bezahlen, aber das ist ok. Mit so einem Controller habe ich das gemacht. Wo bin ich jetzt stehengeblieben?
Da, das ist egal. Das hat funktioniert, aber ich habe es nie eingebaut. Ich habe es ausprobiert,
es hat funktioniert, PiSat über 2km, wunderbar. Man muss ja auch nur einen Byte übertragen,
das war das kein Problem. Ich habe jetzt überlegt, ob ich tatsächlich schon mal sowas wie Things
Network oder so verwenden soll. Das ist ein öffentliches LoRa Netzwerk mit mehreren Empfängern,
aber das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt habe, war in der Nähe dort kein Empfänger, der
bis zum Friedhof gekommen ist. Deswegen werde ich es wahrscheinlich wieder so machen. Ich
will dieses Projekt jetzt nochmal neu angehen. Das war mir zu sehr gebastelt aus einer Box
und einem Sensor, den ich verbuddeln muss. Ich habe mir jetzt überlegt, wäre es nicht
sinnvoll, so einen Sensor hier zu nehmen, der ist Bluetooth Low Energy, da habe ich sogar
noch welche da, die sind dafür gedacht, um Bodenfeuchtigkeit zu messen. Dieser Sensor,
der kann ja im Prinzip passiv in den Bodengesteck da bleiben und ich frage einfach per Bluetooth
Low Energy alle vier Stunden vor einem ESP, den lege ich dann einfach hinten schräg unter
den Grabstein drunter, das sieht keiner, dann mache ich eine IP67-Box hin, mache den ESP
rein, mache vielleicht 1200 mAh schon Akku rein und dann fragt er einfach alle drei,
vier Stunden diesen Sensor ab und schickt das über LoRa heim an das Gateway bzw. ja
an den Receiver und ich glaube, das ist eine deutlich sinnvollere Variante, weil das hier
ist schon für den Outdoor-Einsatz gedacht und ich denke, wenn ich das nur alle drei,
vier Stunden abfrage, dann braucht das auch nicht viel, dann hält das bestimmt auch zwei,
drei Jahre die Batterie hier drin. Ja und ich glaube, das ist ganz cool. Das werde ich
demnächst wahrscheinlich dann auch mal angehen und wieder basteln. Ja, das nur so am ran.
Ja genau und dafür muss ich halt überlegen, dafür wollte ich jetzt vielleicht noch ein
paar Sachen einkaufen. Wobei, wenn ich mir zu Recht überlege, eigentlich muss ich dafür
nichts einkaufen, weil ich alles da habe. Ich habe genug Mi Flora-Sensoren da und ich
habe auch genug Boards dafür da. Ich muss dafür eigentlich gar nichts einkaufen. Das
macht nichts, weil der Sender, der Sender kommt ja nur unter den Grabstein. Also so ein
Teil hier, so ein Controller kommt in, kommt in eine Box, in eine wasserdichte Box mit
einem 1200 mAh Akku. Den verstecke ich hinterm Grabstein oder schräg unterm Grabstein. Der
eigentliche Sensor wird ja dann so ein Ding und der kommt ganz normal in die Erde rein.
So und was für Boxen, so ganz billige IP Box, umso billiger, umso besser, so teile
hier. Muss man mal gucken, der 12 Euro für eine Box ist natürlich komplett hängen geblieben.
Muss man mal gucken, manchmal gibt es sogar Angebote, 6 Euro für 10 Stück oder sowas
in der Richtung. Das finde ich nicht, finde ich verkehrt. Was ist denn mit euch los hier?
Ist das so teuer? Sowas. Ja solche Boxen in der Richtung habe ich ein paar. Das reicht
für Outdoor, zumal es ja auch noch geschützt und am Grabstein liegt. Ja und das werde
ich dann nächstes Mal wieder bauen, weil das ist eine wirklich praktische Geschichte
zu wissen, gerade im Sommer zu wissen, ob man wieder dahin muss oder nicht. Geht da
zwar eh regelmäßig hin, aber halt nicht so oft. Dann nochmal ganz kurz für dich. Ich
habe vor einer Weile versucht, was zu bauen und zwar aus einem Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor
und einem sehr sparsamen Microcontroller, damit ich mir schicken lassen konnte, die
Bodenfeuchtigkeit des Grabes meiner Großeltern von Opa und Oma. Der Friedhof ist ungefähr
1-2 Kilometer weg und ich habe das ausprobiert, das funktioniert wunderbar. Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor,
Microcontroller, Deep Sleep und alle 4-5 Stunden Abfragen. Funktioniert wunderbar. Auch die
Übertragung funktioniert wunderbar. Es war mir aber ein bisschen viel gebastelt, sodass
ich es nie wirklich installiert habe. Und jetzt bin ich gerade am überlegen, mache
ich nicht Wessi und 2.0 dafür, weil es gerade im Sommer praktisch ist zu wissen, ob man
hingehen muss, die Blumen gießen oder nicht. Im Sommer ist es halt so, manchmal musst du
da eine Woche nicht hin, manchmal musst du alle zwei Tage hin, wenn es besonders warm
ist. Das heißt die Bodenfeuchtigkeit vom Grab zu wissen ist echt nicht verkehrt. Zumal
es bei mir in Laufreichweite ist und da kann ich ohne Probleme mittags hinlaufen. Das heißt
ich würde da drauf gucken und stellen fest, Bodenfeuchtigkeit ist gering, ich gehe da
mittags mal hin und gieße eine Runde. Bei der RGB Beleuchtung zu sehen war, ja das ist
dann der nächste. Wenn ich da irgendwann auch mal liege Leute, wenn ich da irgendwann auch
mal liege, dann kommt RGB LEDs drauf. Easy. Das darf man bestimmt nicht. Das darf man
bestimmt nicht. Da kommt bestimmt irgendjemand und sagt nein, nein, nein, hier, dass so unzüchtige
Dinger auf dem Friedhof das gehen. Wer kauft das dem Friedhof, die würden das safe kaufen,
da müsste ich das ja supporten. Eigentlich ist die Idee ja total simpel. Also man könnte,
wisst ihr was Leute, eigentlich könnte man das richtig gut so was machen, weil diese
Sensoren kosten nicht viel. Die Mi Flora, die kosten nicht viel. Und es würde ein Controller
reichen pro Reihe oder pro Gruppe sogar. Dann würde man quasi auf jedes, das könnte man
ja auch auf irgendwelche Gewächshäuser übertragen, aber da haben die sowas ja mit Sicherheit
schon. Würdest du überall reinstecken und dann würdest du einen Controller machen, der
das Bluetooth Low Energy empfängt und dann weiter schickt. Über per Lora zum Beispiel
und da hast du ja auch Sichtlinien auf so einem kompletten Friedhofsgebiet. Eigentlich
eine richtig geile, für einen Garten ist das nice. Für einen Garten verwende ich die
Dinger ja auch. Die sind ja eigentlich auch für einen Garten gedacht. Also ich verwende
aktuell 4 Stück davon, 3 Stück im Hof und einen im Kühlschrank. Die Dinger sind wirklich
richtig gute Universal Sensoren. Also eigentlich gedacht für hier so Pflanzen im Flur oder
auf dem Balkon oder im Hof, aber ich verwende die im Hof bei ein paar Blumen, aber einen
habe ich auch im Kühlschrank liegen, um zu gucken, ob der nicht irgendwelche Probleme
hat. Ja, ich habe dir den Kühlschrank geschmissen und da ist, hier drinnen ist ein Temperatursensor,
ein Licht, also ein Helligkeitssensor und ein Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor. Gut, den Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor
brauche ich nicht, aber Temperatur und Licht ist im Kühlschrank optimal. Du kriegst eine
Benachrichtigung, wenn der Kühlschrank kaputt ist. Ja, also wenn mein Kühlschrank quasi
länger als 5 Minuten über 15 Grad geht, ansonsten könnte es ja auch ein Messfehler sein. Kriege
ich eine Mette bzw. wird auch rot im Dashboard. Der ist normalerweise schwank, der zwischen
irgendwie immer so hin und her, je nachdem wie der Kompressor da gerade arbeitet, sieht
man auch schön im Graf so immer zwischen 8 und 6 Grad so hin und her und das Licht ist
auch wunderbar, weil dann siehst du, ob du die Tür aufgelassen hast vom Kühlschrank.
Wenn der Lichtsensor Licht empfängt, dann ist die Kühlschranktür auf. Du wolltest
rausfinden, ob das Licht ausfällt, wenn man die Tür zumacht, das wusste ich, weil man
kann die Tür ja auch leicht zumachen und dann kann man reingucken, dann geht es schon
los, aber selbst dann ist noch hell drin, sodass der Lichtsensor empfängt. Also wenn
ich vergessen habe, die Tür zuzumachen, dann ist hier das Licht an und wenn der Kühlschrank
kaputt ist, dann geht die Temperatur hoch. Also das ist tatsächlich ein richtig big brain
Sensor, den man für alles mögliche verwenden kann. Ja, richtig cool. Ja, weil irgendjemand
vorhin nach sinnvollen Heimautomatisierungs Sachen gefragt hat, so nach und nach, falls
derjenige noch dabei ist, kommt man glaube ich so halbwegs dahinter, was ich bei mir
habe. Ich habe beispielsweise am Teich im Garten, habe ich per Sea-Wave, wegen der Reichweite
und Low-Energy, per Sea-Wave einen Sensor angebunden, nämlich ein DS-28 Sensor, wie
ist das? Sensor DS, der da, das ist ein wasserdichter Temperatursensor, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
wieder, wieder, wasserdichter Temperatursensor und den habe ich in Teich gehängt im Garten
und da erkenne ich jetzt gerade seine Fische drin, also ansonsten wäre mir das egal, wenn
da keine Fische drin wären, aber die Fische haben damit Probleme, wenn das zu sehr zu
friert. So, und deswegen mache ich das jetzt so, ich habe diesen Sensor hinten im Teich
hängen und wenn dann im Winter quasi die Wassertemperatur fällt und es droht zuzufrieren,
dann sehe ich das auch bei mir im Dashboard und weiß, aha, ich muss mal hinten den Garten
und den Teich abdecken oder wir müssen mal hinter den Garten den Teich abdecken. Also
das sind alles sinnvolle Anwendungsgebiete, die einem wirklich auch einen Mehrwert bringen,
wenn man das hat. Wahrscheinlich ist es in Zukunft so, dass ich die natürlich im Winter
gar nicht mehr zudecken muss, wahrscheinlich ist es dann zu warm, leider, aber es ist auf
jeden Fall gut zu wissen, weil wenn das zufriert, dann geht entweder der Teich an den Rändern,
wenn man Pech hat, kaputt und die Fische mögen das auch nicht so sehr, wenn es zu sehr zufriert,
zu lang und zu dick. Richtig Hobby-Buster, klar, das ist ja das geile da dran. Man lernt
dabei unglaublich viel und man kann damit noch sinnvolle Sachen machen. Man könnte natürlich
auch hingehen, einfach fertige Lösungen kaufen, aber fertige Lösungen, gerade in einem Gebiet,
was so unglaublich individuelle Lösungen braucht, ist, finde ich, fertige Sachen kaufen
komplett ohne Individualisierungsmöglichkeit nicht so gut. Richtig agil, genau. Poolheizung
ist doof. Könnte man machen. Was ich machen könnte zum Beispiel, ich habe da eine Pumpe,
die Sauerstoff reinpumpt, dann blubbert es ein bisschen und dadurch, dass es blubbert,
friert das nicht zu, weil sich das bisschen bewegt, das Wasser. Kann man sich glaube ich
ganz gut vorstellen. Und das habe ich auch schon überlegt, ob ich es nicht so einstellen
soll, dass es einfach dauerhaft blubbert, wenn es unter einer gewissen Temperatur geht
und dann muss ich halt später zudecken, weil ich mache das unglaublich gern. Teich abdecken
ist eins meiner unbeliebtesten jährlichen Arbeiten. Ist bestimmt auch billiger. Ja,
auf jeden Fall. Allein schon wenn du den Preisunterschied siehst, wenn Leute sich irgendwelche Philips
U-Dinger daheim hinstellen, ihr Haus damit ausstatten und irgendwie erst mal 800€ ausgeben
und man das mit Hirn macht und sich das Richtige kauft, kriegt man ein ähnliches, wenn nicht
besseres Ergebnis, besser integriert und für viel, viel weniger Geld. Weil man eben kein
RGB braucht zu 90% nur da wo es wirklich sinnvoll ist. An die meisten Leute halt RGB kaufen.
So, davon brauche ich aber keine Sensor und ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich da jetzt genau
drauf gekommen bin. Geh mal weg. Wann machen wir wieder Hetzener Stonks? Am Wochenende.
Ich muss unbedingt noch ein paar Streams machen. Für mehr Easy Money. Und außerdem will ich
auch, dass sie was für ihr Geld kriegen. Was ist aus deinem Garten geworden? Gärtner?
Ich habe keinen Gärtner. Du meinst das, wo ich mir letztens überlegt habe, was das kostet,
wenn ich mir einen Gärtner hole? Nein, den habe ich nicht gemacht. Ich habe auch gar
nicht weiter geguckt, was das kostet. Ich hatte letztens für Levi in dem Stream nicht
dabei. Ich habe letztens überlegt, weil ich hasse Gartenarbeit Leute. Ich hasse mega Gartenarbeit.
Ich hasse mega Gartenarbeit. Ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich mir nicht irgendeinen hole,
der mir mal zumindest mal so die Hecken gerade macht und vielleicht guckt, dass man irgendwie
wieder bis zur Hütte hinten durchkommt gescheit. Habe ich mir aber nur nicht weiter mit beschäftigt.
Naja, so was habe ich noch auf meiner Einkaufsliste stehen? Katzenbrunnen hatten wir schon. Auch
Katzenfutter. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig spannend. LED China Chinesen
Kram hatten wir jetzt. Hatten wir das jetzt schon? Ja, nee wollte ich nachher gucken.
Genau. iPhone 11 Case ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig dringend. Laura Friedhof Zeug habe ich auch
geguckt. Brauche ich nichts? Ach ja, jetzt fällt mir noch was ein. Vielleicht
damals noch bei Amazon eben. Ups, ne haben wir nicht. Letztens hat mir doch jemand im
Stream so eine Kamera empfohlen. TP Link. Oh, Schluck auf. Fuck. Irgendwie sowas. Letztens
hat einer im Stream gemeint, hier, hol dir das Ding, weil ich gesagt habe, ich will eine,
die ich schwenken kann und eine, wo ich keine App brauche, wo ich über RTSP abfragen kann.
Hatte jemand gesagt, hier, kauf dir das Ding, das kann das alles, was du haben willst. Tja,
hab ich gemacht. Und wisst ihr was? Funktioniert nicht. Weil, eine Sache habe ich ja nicht bedacht,
eine Sache habe ich ja nicht bedacht, damit das Ganze funktioniert oder eventuell mal funktioniert,
ich muss den Kram initial hier erstmal einrichten. Und um es initial einzurichten, brauche ich
die offizielle App und muss meine WLAN-Passwörter und Credentials in der offiziellen App eingeben,
was ich ja schon mal sehr suboptimal gelöst finde. Ich meine, ich kann es umgehen und werde
ich wahrscheinlich auch umgehen, indem ich mich einfach mit meinem Handy in mein IoT-Netz
connecte, wo man nicht ins Internet kann, dann die App drauf haue oder am besten mit
irgendeinem Android-Tablet, habe ich ja genug von, mich connecte und in das IoT-Netz gehe,
das dort drüber mache und dann die App lösche und das Tablet wieder ausmache. Aber es ist
doof, es ist doof. Ich verstehe nicht, wo das Problem ist, dass man diese Kameras so
ausliefert, dass man sie einrichten kann ohne App. Das ist richtig lost, ja. Wisst ihr,
es ist ja kein Hexenwerk. Wisst ihr, was man einfach machen könnte? Man würde unten einfach
ein Passwort draufdrucken auf die Kamera, dann zieht ihr es nicht von unten und das
Ding macht ein Tablet auf. Das Ding macht einen Hotspot auf und dann lockst du dich
mit dem Passwort von unten ein und kannst das über den Browser einrichten. Aber ne,
das geht mit den China-Chinesen-Dingern nicht. Warte, ich bin hier falsch. Wo ist der Chat?
Da ist der Chat. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich vor Jahren mal ein Android-Tablet verlost
habe. Das ist richtig. Ich habe vor Jahren mal ein Max-FPS Tegra Note 7 glaube ich verlost.
Warum willst du es ohne App machen? Weil ich kein Bock auf China-Chinesen-App habe. Ihh.
Warum findet er das nicht mehr? Irgendwas unter Linus Tech Tips hat Werbung dafür gemacht.
Ja, ich habe das mal verlost vor einer Weile, das stimmt. Ich habe mich dazu überreden
lassen, damals, weil Nvidia gesagt hat, du kriegst ein Tablet für dich und kannst eins
verlosen und machst halt ein Video über die Verlosung. Heute würde ich das wahrscheinlich
nicht machen, weil ich das Tablet damals eigentlich gar nicht gebraucht habe und mich dadurch
habe jebaiten lassen durch, ah ich bekomme noch ein neues kostenloses Tablet. Richtig
harte Marketing-Jebait-Aktion. A New World Waiting Room, kommt denn das raus? Ist das
heute soweit? Das ist doch morgen erst, oder? Ist das nicht morgen? Ist das nicht Dienstag
erst? 28. September. Yep. Morgen früh um 8. Darf ich da aufschließen? Du wirst dir das
morgen geben. Oder was? Schon pre-ordert? Also ich glaube immer noch nicht, dass New
World das riesen Ding wird, wie sich das vielleicht einige vorstellen. Aber ich glaube auch nicht,
dass es der komplette Reihenfall wird. Ich glaube, das wird seine Nische treffen, nämlich
Leute, die diese Art von PvP und Fraktions-Gameplay mögen. Ich glaube nicht, dass es das nächste,
ok ich sag jetzt nicht das nächste World of Warcraft wird, weil das ist ausgelutscht,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass es das nächste Millionen-Subscription-MMO wird über die
nächsten Jahre. Aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass es down geht, Instant. Ich glaube, das
wird am Anfang relativ viel Hype haben. Das sieht man jetzt ja auch, und auch die ganzen
Streamer und die ganzen Kacknoobs kommen dann wieder in die Streamer-Fraktion und nerven
rum und springen den ganzen Tag um ihren Streamer, wissen aber eigentlich gar nicht, wie man
MMOs gescheit spielt. Deswegen nie, nie auf die Streamer-Fraktion gehen, sondern höchstens,
vielleicht auf den Streamer-Server, ok, aber nicht in die Streamer-Fraktion gehen. Das
heißt wirklich Dauerloss vorprogrammiert, wenn man da mitmacht. Das liegt aber nicht
an den Streamern, sondern das liegt an den Kacknoobs, die da mitspielen und das hat keinen
Sinn. Und die sind aber nach einem Monat wieder weg. Spätestens wenn der Streamer
weg ist, sind die auch wieder weg. Und dementsprechend glaube ich, wird New Worlds schon eine gewisse
Fanbase halten können, aber halt nicht so dieses riesengroße Millionen-MMO werden,
wie man sich das vielleicht erhofft. Vielleicht liege ich falsch, vielleicht liege ich richtig,
ich würde es nicht sagen, wenn ich nicht glauben würde, dass ich richtig liege. Zuschauer
gleich Kacknoobs, die meisten, naja, es ist die Wahrheit, Wahrheit schmerzt, die meisten
Zuschauer sind Kacknoobs, das ist einfach so. Ich rede jetzt nicht von Elektrotechnik im
Bastel, bei mir, da sind die meisten Leute sogar deutlich schlauer als ich, was das
angeht. Der Chat bei mir nicht, der Chat, also mein Chat hat natürlich absolut Big
Brain, Huge IQ, das liegt ja auch daran, ich habe es vielleicht heute noch gar nicht
erwähnt, jeder Prime-Sub erhöht den Durchschnitts-IQ der Zuschauer, deswegen ist das bei mir
ja auch kein Problem. Ich habe so viele Prime-Sub mittlerweile bekommen, bekomme immer weiter
so viele Prime-Sub, dann ist das IQ-technisch überhaupt kein Problem, deswegen ist der
Chat bei mir auch so schlau. Aber normalerweise sind die Standard-Streamer-Zuschauer Kacknoobs
in Games, die spielen das Spiel nur weil es ihr Lieblings-Streamer spielt und haben eigentlich
gar kein Interesse wirklich an dem Game, sondern, guckt bei Asmongold, Asmongold ist das beste
Beispiel für, auch wenn ich den übelst gerne gucke. Die Fans, das ist einfach das low-brainigste,
was du da im Game immer siehst, der lockt sich auf irgendeinen Server ein und es sammelt,
der kann nicht mal in Ruhe spielen, der lockt sich auf einem Server ein und es entsteht
erstmal eine Traube von 500 Spielern um ihn drum herum. Weiß ich ob ihr das schon mal
gesehen habt bei ihm, das sind zum größten Teil absolute Kacknoobs in dem Game. Was,
deswegen, ich weiß nicht, wann kommt endlich das Streaming-Content, ich weiß nicht genau
was du meinst, aber ich bin nicht eingelockt auf YouTube. Nö, nicht nur, das sind nicht
nur kleine Kinder, gar nicht mal, auch bestimmt, aber das sind halt übelste, das ist ja gar
nicht mal was Ultra-Negatives, das sind halt meistens Leute, das sind halt so, mögen
die ein oder andere Kinder sein, wobei die Kinder, die spielen eigentlich zum größten
Teil wahrscheinlich eher so eine Mischung aus Minecraft, Fortnite und sonst was, weiß
nicht was gerade angesagt ist, aber das sind einfach Ultra-Casual-Spieler, die nicht wissen
wie man ein MMO ordentlich spielt. Ich will mir jetzt nicht anmaßen, dass ich irgendwas
über New World Gameplay-Technik sagen kann, aber das ist zumindest die Erfahrung, die
ich aus allen anderen MMOs bisher gemacht habe, wir haben einige gespielt, das sind halt einfach
so mega Ultra-Casual-Spieler. Genau, und halt zusätzlich Leute eben wegen dem Streamer
in das Game gehen und nicht gehen. Bestes Beispiel ist New World, ich weiß nicht, äh,
wer war das eben, der das geschrien hat, der Fat Dude, glaub ich, ähm, das ist das Beste,
ohne Scheiß, man sollte sich da nicht so sehr an andere, und New World hat ja auch Vorteile,
New World, was ich bei New World wirklich cool finde, ist, dass es seit langem ein MMO
ist, das auf Spieler-Interaktion setzt. Mal wieder, und nicht auf anonymes Go Go Go, Buff,
GG, sonst was, ähm, anonymes Dungeon-Finder. Also das, New World hat unbestreitbar auch
seine Seiten, die ich cool finde. So, ähm, jetzt hab ich vergessen, was ich eigentlich
davor sagen wollte. Ja. Aber wie gesagt, das Game an sich muss ja nicht schlecht sein, aber
ich glaube nicht, dass es ein Game ist, was wirklich der breiten Masse auf Dauer Spaß
macht, und schon gar nicht den ganzen Kacknoobs, die den ganzen Streamern immer nachhännen.
Ach ja, genau, jetzt weiß ich wieder, jetzt weiß ich wieder, was ich sagen wollte, äh,
vielleicht hast du das mitbekommen, oder bist da ein bisschen mehr drin, wenn du New World
spielst, äh, Fat, Fat Dude, ähm, man hat's ja gesehen, es gab zur Beta ein Server, wo
alle deutschen, wo alle deutschen Streamer hin sind, und auch die ganzen, äh, Streaming,
Gameboys, Casual, Kacknoobs, Noobs, was auch immer. So, und da ging's dann darum, äh,
wer auf diesem, welche der Fraktionen auf diesem Server eben besonders owned. So, und
dreimal dürft ihr raten, es gibt drei Fraktionen in diesem Spiel. Ich glaube, in der Beta
auf diesem Server waren's einmal die Franzosen, die Franzosen-Community, die deutsche Streamer-Community
und noch irgendwas, ich hab's wieder vergessen. So, und ratet mal, wer haushoch verloren hat
von den Fraktionen in New World, in der Beta. Wenn ich das so sage, dann ist natürlich
schon klar, was rausgekommen ist, aber, ihr wisst was, die Streamer-Fraktion hat haushoch
verloren, gar nicht wegen den Streamern, gar nicht wegen den Streamern, ich glaube, Cronk
hatte Hochwasser zwischendurch oder so, an den Streamern liegt's aber wirklich nicht,
es liegt an den ganzen Kacknoobs, die keine Ahnung haben, wie man MMOs spielt. Die Franzosen
haben gerockt, die haben's richtig gemacht. Die Franzosen haben, ähm, Theorie crafted
as fuck, was man machen muss bei einem neuen MMO. Bei einem MMO geht's weniger um Aiming
oder Super Mechanics wie in CS, da geht's um Game-Knowledge und Ahnung, was, äh, was
passiert. So, die Franzosen haben's richtig gemacht. Die Franzosen haben sich an das Questboard
gehockt und haben das Town, ich frag mich nicht genau, wie es in New World heißt, dieses
Town-Questing-System, Abused, wie sonst was. Die Franzosen haben einfach an dem Questboard
gestanden, die Leute sind durch die Welt gerannt, haben die Quests erledigt und die Leute, die
an dem Questboard standen, haben die Quests abgegeben, das heißt, die konnten quasi
im, wie schnell das ging, Minutentakt Quests abgeben und es hat brutal Bonus, XP und alles
gegeben. So, und die haben das noch gemacht, bevor es gepatcht wurde. Und als die deutschen,
die deutsche, äh, Streamer-Kakno-Fraktion, ich meine, nicht die Streamer, sondern einfach
die ganzen Fanboys das mitbekommen haben, dass man so relativ schnell leveln kann, war
das Ganze schon gepatcht, Pech gehabt, ja. Das ist wieder der Beweis für, geht auf gar
keinen Fall auf einen Streaming-Server in die Streamer-Fraktion, wenn ihr den Game ernsthaft
spielen wollt und auch mal was reißen wollt. Es ist einfach nur frustrierend. Ihr könnt
ruhig auf einen Streaming-Server gehen, geht aber nicht in die Streamer-Fraktion. Auf
gar keinen Fall. Dann ist da, dann ist Dauer los und äh, sonst war es vorprogrammiert.
Oh mein. Ja, genug geflamed jetzt. Ist so. So wird es, ich weiß nicht, ob, ich hab keine
Ahnung, wird es, vielleicht, vielleicht weiß ich nicht, wird es zur Release wieder irgendeine
Competition oder so geben, so irgendwie Streamer versus andere Streamer oder sowas, haben die
da wieder irgendwas geplant? Ich hab das jetzt nicht so verfolgt, ich werd's mir auch nicht
kaufen. Dafür gibt's grad viel zu viele andere Spiele, die ich spielen muss und komm eh nicht
hinterher. Ich hab seit 12 Tagen kein Video gemacht auf YouTube. Okay, der ist ja, du machst
es richtig, du interessierst dich für den ganzen Mist einfach nicht. Noch, das ist noch
viel besser. Äh, wie gesagt, an den Streamern wird das nicht liegen. Die Streamer machen
das im Rahmen ihrer Möglichkeiten. Man kann von einem Streamer ja auch nicht erwarten,
dass er ein unbeliebtes Spiel weiterspielt oder sowas. Das ist bescheuert, das ist nur
zum Anschieben gut. Das Problem ist, die Leute, die der Streamer mitbringt, die dann quasi
damit, mit, die er so mitzieht, das sind halt meistens die Ultra-Noobs oder die Ultra-Casuals
und Leute, die absolut keine Games spielen können, zu, zum größten Teil. Was ich zur
Zeit spiele, ich spiele mit dem Fabian Diablo 2 und was mir mega Spaß macht, ist das aktuelle
Pathfinder und es gibt noch einige Spiele in meiner Steam-Library, die ich in letzter
Zeit geholt hab, die ich auch noch spielen muss. Also aktuell ist tatsächlich endlich
so das erste Mal seit langer Zeit, wo viele Games rausgekommen sind, wo ich richtig Bock
drauf hab. Ist leider nichts, was man großartig auf YouTube, und dann kommt Battlefield auch
noch. Da kommt der Battlefield. Ich hab vergessen, wann jetzt Release ist, die haben das ganze
Jahr verschoben. Ja, hier. Ist das schon das Verschobene? Das ist schon das Verschobene,
ne? Ja, das ist schon das Verschobene. Ansonsten hätte es, glaub ich, nächsten Monat kommen
sollen. Das kommt ja auch noch raus. Age of Empires IV ist auf Far Cry. Far Cry kommt
auch noch, das werd ich mir auf jeden Fall angucken. Ich hoffe, sie haben bisschen die
Kurve gekriegt. Also, es gibt wirklich viel zur Zeit. Ich freu mich richtig, ich freu
mich echt, weil ich hab in den letzten paar Jahren auch immer so gesagt, irgendwie kommt
nur Scheiße raus, irgendwie kommt nichts raus, was mir gefällt. Ab und zu mal irgendwas,
aber nicht, um wirklich so meine Zeit, die ich eigentlich zum Spielen hätte, zu füllen.
So, und da freu ich mich echt drauf. Also, jetzt noch die ganzen Sachen zu spielen und
dann Battlefield, wenn's rauskommt. Und vor allem Dezember hab ich komplett Urlaub. Hat
mit Battlefield nichts zu tun, passt aber ganz gut dazu. Ja, nice. Battlefield Beta, ja,
da darf ich leider nichts dazu sagen. Leider nicht. Ich hab unterschrieben, dass ich dazu
nichts sagen darf. Aber ich kann sagen, lange wird's nicht mehr dauern. Ich glaube, das
ist nicht... ist doch nicht zu viel League. Lange wird's nicht mehr dauern. Ich weiß
was zu. Ja. Ich hab aber unterschrieben, dass ich nichts sag. Deswegen sag ich auch
nichts. Außer, dass es nicht mehr lange dauert. Ach ja, und dass die meisten Leagues, ja,
nachdem sich die meisten Leagues ja eher als wahr herausgestellt haben, wisst ihr es wahrscheinlich
eh besser als ich. Freu mich schon auf meine Next-Gen-Konsole im November. Also, wie wär's
für ein PC? Nochmal angemerkt, man kann ja jeder machen, was er will, ja. Aber wie wär's
für ein PC? Ich weiß, mein PC ist vier Jahre alt und da läuft immer noch alles drauf.
Ich weiß, mein PC ist vier Jahre alt und da läuft immer noch alles drauf. Es ist jetzt
nicht so, als würden PCs schnell nicht mehr aktuell sein. Was suchst du denn gar nichts?
Das hab ich schon längst, das hab ich nur zum Zeigen aufgemacht. Da hat mich jemand
gefragt, wo ich mein WLED Zeug drauf laufen hab. Da hab ich gesagt, das meiste läuft
auf dem Daewon Mini. Aber WLED ist das gut, das kannst du faktisch überall drauf laufen
lassen. Es geht mittlerweile sogar auf ESP32, also das läuft eigentlich überall. ESP32,
ESP866, alles Mögliche. Ja, aber das meiste hab ich halt hier drauf laufen. Pog. Ich hab
auch den Switch gemacht. Ich hab mir die aktuellen Konsolen nicht gekauft, das ist die erste
Konsolengeneration. Nur hab ich lustigerweise gestern mit dem Fabian erst drüber geredet.
Das ist die erste Konsolengeneration, die ich mir nicht gekauft habe und die ich auch
nicht habe, also vorhabe mir zu kaufen, die PS5 und die Xbox. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie
die aktuelle Xbox heißt. Meine Güte, die Xbox-Benahmung von Microsoft ist so fail.
Xbox Series X heißt sie, glaub ich. Xbox Series X ist die große und Xbox Series S ist die
kleine. Aber was ist kleine? Die weniger, mit ein bisschen weniger Power. Stimmt das?
Ich glaub schon. MarioXTB, danke schön für den Sub. Und ich sehe für mich aktuell keinen
Grund das zu machen. Ich hab die letzte Konsolengeneration gekauft. Ich hab's hier liegen. Wo ist
es? Wo ist der Controller? Sekunde. Hier. Da. Verstaubt. Verstaubt as fuck. Aber hier.
Xbox. Steht drauf. Day One Edition 2013. Xbox One. Ich war quasi einer der ersten, der
dieses Teil hatte. Und wie oft hatte ich's an? Keine Ahnung. Viertelstunde oder so. Ich
hab es nicht benutzt. Für nix. Ich hab nichts, nichts damit gemacht. Gar nichts. Und die
PS4 genauso. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo sie steht. Wo ist die PS4 überhaupt? Da. Steht auf der
360 obendrauf. PS4 hab ich nicht mal mehr am Strom dran. Seit zwei Jahren oder so. 20
Stunden angehabt. Wenn's hochkommt. Wenn's hochkommt. Ohne Scheiß. Die Konsolen sind
viel neu. Naja, zu 360 Zeiten war's immer noch die beste Konsole. War ein paar Exklusivspieler
abgesehen, die du auf der Playstation hattest. War die 360, finde ich. Wenn man Online-Spiele
spielen wollte, auf jeden Fall. Ohne Frage eigentlich die bessere Konsole. Den Vorteil
die die PS3 hatte war halt, dass das PSN kostenlos war zur damaligen Zeit. Aber die Spiele sind
meistens besser gelaufen auf der 360 und Xbox Live war halt meilenweit vom PSN damals.
Allein schon Game-unabhängige Partys und sowas. Das war halt einfach besser. Damals. Die letzte
Konsolengeneration nicht und die aktuelle weiß ich nicht. Ich mag übrigens den 360-Controller
immer noch. Mir ist der Xbox 360-Controller tatsächlich lieber als der Xbox One-Controller.
Ich weiß nicht ob der wie der Xbox Series X-Controller ist. Ich kann's schlecht beschreiben. Warum?
Ich find's schwammiger mit diesen etwas kleineren Sticks vom Xbox One-Controller versus dem
360-Controller. Ist alles Gewöhnungsart. Die Playstation-Controller bin ich nie richtig
schwamm geworden. Ich finde, ich hab ja auch immer noch Xbox 360-Controller rumliegen
mit USB und sogar noch so einem Wireless-Ding. Ich weiß gar nicht ob man das überhaupt noch
kaufen kann. 360-Controller. Ne, gibt nur noch Nachbauten. Guckt. Ja, also ich hab noch
Originale Xbox 360-Controller und paar. Drei Stück noch insgesamt. Ah guck mal hier Play
and Charge. Und die werd ich auch bis zum Ausleiern benutzen. Ja. Ne, war das nicht
Lizard Squad? War das nicht Lizard Squad mit Sony? War das Anonymous? War das nicht Lizard
Squad? Ich krieg's immer zusammen. Ist auch egal. Das war noch andere Zeiten. Aber heute,
ich wüsste ganz ehrlich auch gar nicht mehr warum ich mir das kaufen soll. Das meiste
kommt auf dem PC raus. Klar, es gibt noch die ein oder anderen Exklusivsachen. Manche
Sachen kommen halt auch ein bisschen verspätet erst auf dem PC raus. Richtig dumme Kombination
ist natürlich wenn dann sowas kommt wie kommt ein Jahr später auf dem PC raus und dann
noch ein Jahr Epic-Exklusiv. Aber ich glaub sowas kommt eigentlich nie vor. Aber wäre
theoretisch möglich. Aber ansonsten klar gibt Exklusiv-Spiele. Wenn's da mal wirklich
irgendwas gibt wo ich sag, das muss ich unbedingt spielen und das ist Sony-Exklusiv. Ja vielleicht
hol ich mir da noch einen. Aber aktuell seh ich nicht ein mit nem PS5 zu holen. Das ist
wie gesagt, das ist die erste Konsolengeneration seit, ja fast seit dem Super Nintendo. Oder
sagen wir mal zumindest seit dem N64. Die ich nicht hab und auch überhaupt keinen Bedarf
sehe und mich das irgendwie dahin zieht das zu kaufen. Ihr God of War ist aber PS4. PS4
hab ich ja. Ich kenne das von der PS5. Es kommt ein neues... Das hab ich gesehen. Da
konnte ich übrigens das Geflamer nicht verstehen. Da haben die Leute gesagt, hoh lull neues
God of War sieht ja aus wie God of War davor. Naja es ist jetzt nicht so als wäre das schlecht
gewesen. Wie das letzte ausgeschottet. Die haben so ziemlich alles aus der PS4 rausgeholt
was irgendwie ging und da kommt bestimmt noch ein bisschen was obendrauf. Ach versteh nicht.
Also da ein bisschen zu früh geflamet. Genau das gibt es jetzt auch auf dem PC. Das gibt
es jetzt auch auf dem PC seit... Ist doch gar nicht so lange raus. Ich glaube es ist
erst ein paar Monate auf dem PC raus. Guck mal. Guck mal das rausgekommen ist. Das ist auch
noch ein Spiel was spielen will. 1913 exakt. Ist auch noch eins was spielen will. Ok es
ist schon ein Jahr her. Ich hab nix gesagt. Ah gut. Das neue Diablo? Ja das bin ich gerade
mit Fabian am spielen. Ist der eigentlich on? Alter er war wieder ewig on gestern. Kann
das sein? Nee das Diablo 2 Streams glaubt ihr. Die Diablo 2 Streams sind langweilig
als fuck. Ihr könnt den Stream beim Fabian gucken. Von gestern ist es mega langweilig.
Wir labern sinnloses Zeug und grinden vor uns hin. Das ist langweilig. Die Diablo 2
Stream ist nicht spannend. Ich könnte mal wieder einen Battlefield 3 Stream machen in
nächster Zeit. Das werde ich machen wenn Battlefield 2042 Release in nähe rückt. Dann
muss ich mich wieder ein bisschen warm spielen in Battlefield. Dann machen wir wahrscheinlich
mal so eine Woche lang Battlefield 3 Streams, dass ich mich wieder ein bisschen einspielen
kann. Ja. Eats. Eats. Richtig Eats. Leute ich bin jetzt schon 3 Stunden 40 on. Ich hab
echt schon richtig trockenen Hals. Wir sind mit dem einkaufen nicht so wirklich vorwärts
gekommen. Spielst du auf Battlefield auch Viewer Games? Also es konnten bisher immer
alle Leute rein joinen. Ich hab nie irgendwie großartiges Geheimnis rumgegangen. Was ich
aber überhaupt nicht ab kann, ist, wo ich dann auch mal die Layreihe, weswegen ich auch
die Layreihe reinmachen muss, dass es sogar in Battlefield, man glaubt das nicht, in
einem Spiel was 10 Jahre alt ist. Oder wann war das, wann kam das raus? Ja. Es gibt Streamsniper
in Battlefield 3. Es gibt Stream, das muss man sich mal auf die Zunge zergehen. Streamsniper
in Battlefield 3 im Jahre fast 2022. Streamsniper. Das hab ich nicht für Möglichkeiten, aber
es ist so. Es ist so. Aber gut, warum soll es das auch nicht geben? Ich meine es gibt
überall Streamsniper. Warum soll es keine Streamsniper in Battlefield 3 geben? Ne, ne,
ne. Na gut Leute, ich geh jetzt auf. Mal gucken, ob ich irgendjemand hier noch hosten kann von
den kleinen, wenn ich selbst folge, zeig mal her. Keiner da. Ja, lange genug geschwätzt.
Einkaufen hat nicht so geflutscht. Heute machen wir jedenfalls anders weiter. Ist jetzt nicht
eilig. Alles klar. Heute wir sehen uns. Bis denn. Macht's gut. See you.